So
Leak
So auch ich muss mein Headset entknoten kurz so
Auf geht's hat Twitch schon gecheckt dass der Stream on ist
Okay, jetzt wird die Musik grad ein wenig
ex exquisite
Ja jetzt hat Twitch gecheckt dass der Stream on ist
Leute Hacker Mode aktiviert
Hallo Chat
Ne Moment wie muss ich wie muss ich winken so muss ich winken oder dass man was sieht
Hallo Chat ja ich habe gedacht wenn ich die Kamera und den Tisch und den ganzen Krempel schon mal hier stehen habe
Dann können wir das auch heute noch mal für was verwenden
Oh Leute ich muss doch schnell was zu trinken holen ich muss doch ganz schnell was zu trinken holen
Ne ne das
Eins eins kann ich euch sagen es gibt zwei Sachen
Die müsst ihr machen Leona Mama 97 18 Monate Dankeschön
Und wenn ihr die 13 Monate ab das ist Hyper Subscription aber hier mal
Massive Lifehack übrigens Teams hat wieder mal Sound verstellt ne
Ah Yes
Teams Suckt einfach nur Hardcore
So genau wie gesagt ich geh jetzt ich geh mir jetzt erstmal schnell was zu trinken holen
Es gibt einen Salami Emote ja Wupp Wurst also es gibt zwei Sachen
Huge Lifehack Toxie Dankeschön für die 13 Monate Subscription
Also gibt es zwei Sachen die ihr die unbedingt machen müsst wenn ihr den ganzen Tag am Rechner sitzt so wie ich auf der Arbeiten jetzt danach noch mal
Ihr müsst einmal am Tag mindestens eine Stunde rausgehen und euch bewegen
Ohne Scheiß ich hätte nied gedacht dass ich das mal sage aber das ist wirklich nicht ohne
Sonst kriegt man Kopfweh es tut einem der Rücken weh und alles sackt ja
Und ihr müsst viel trinken
Und kriegt ihr nämlich auch Kopfweh und euch Sackt auch
Ordentlich trinken
Und am Tag eine Stunde draußen rumlaufen
Reicht schon
Ihr müsst keine krassen Sportmänner rumgesprinte machen
Eine Stunde am Tag raus
Und sich ein bisschen bewegen
Und trinken
Krasse Fitnesstipps bei mir, ich weiß
Aber das hilft wirklich
Also wenn ihr Rückenschmerzen habt
Wenn ihr Kopfschmerzen habt
Bevor ihr anfängt
Auch wenn ihr hohen Blutdruck habt
Und irgendwelche Pillen nehmt
Geht eine Stunde am Tag raus
Bewegt euch ein bisschen an der Luft
Und trinkt ordentlich was
Gut, als ich das jetzt mal losgeworden bin
Leute, Chat
Ich
Gehe jetzt mal kurz was zu trinken holen
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind
Dann bin ich wieder da
By the way, Band Emote
Anzeige ist raus
Gleich wieder da
Denk fest, du hast mein Headset
Eier
So
Bin ich wieder
Also
Bin jetzt übelst
Die Treppe raufgesprintet
Also
Ich hab so
Passt mal auf, guck mal
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das
Mal gucken, ob ihr das auf der Kamera seht
Ich geh mal kurz ins Vollbild
Ich hab hier so ne Falte im Teppich
Und da hakt das mit meinem
Ist übrigens Shep, die Kamera, ne?
Da hakt das übelst mit meinem Stuhl
Wenn ich da drüber fahr
Wackelt glaub ich die ganze Kamera
Ja, guck mal
Nur wenn ich mit der
Nur wenn ich mit dem Stuhl über die Falte im Teppich fahr
So, wir müssen mal gucken, dass ein bisschen Grat wird
Warte mal, ich mach den Teppichgrat
Dann mach ich den Kameragrat
Das ist so, wisst ihr
Der Tisch ist wirklich äußerst stabil
Was nicht stabil ist, ist der Boden
Das ist hier kein
Kein supermassives Betonzeug
Was der Opa da gebastelt hat, also
Guckt mal, wenn ich jetzt pepo fett hier springe
Das ist nicht der Tisch
Guckt mal, das ist nicht der Tisch, der wackelt
Sondern das ist wirklich der Boden, der wackelt
Und dementsprechend wackelt der Tisch halt auch
So, das kann man ein bisschen Grat machen
Das hier ist Shep
Ah ne, da ist er, diese komischen Dinger
Staub
Der abisolierte Shep ist auch am Start
Der ist ja noch schepper, oder?
Moment, jetzt ist er noch schepper
MonkaS
Eigentlich ist es relativ
Was ist denn hier Shep jetzt?
Das da?
So
Leute, ist es jetzt weniger Shep?
Ja, der Mauszeiger
Da kann ich grad nichts machen
Der Mauszeiger springt immer in die Mitte
Und ich bin grad nicht am Rechner, ich schieb grad den Kram
Übrigens, heute kein Holzfällerhemd
Also
Ja, ich hab mir den, guck mal hier
Das ist wirklich der Boden, der wackelt
Natürlich trägt er auch ein bisschen dazu bei
Dass ich jetzt nicht pepo leicht gewischt bin
Aber Elefant auch nicht
Ja, ich hab mir den Switch geholt
Und im letzten Stream haben wir uns den Switch sogar mal angeguckt
Im Detail
Detail
Im Detail haben wir uns den angeguckt
So
Also
Ich hab mir folgendes gekauft
Ich hab gedacht, das gucken wir uns halt mal im Stream zusammen an
Ich hab mir eine Raspberry Pi 4
Flirk
Flirk Case gekauft
Beste
Und wir probieren das jetzt mal
Hm
Wisst ihr was noch richtig pro wär?
Wenn ich es irgendwie hinkriegen würde
Dass das Overlay auf beiden
Desktops ist
Das ist Manjaro Linux mit i3 WM
Ja
Ich mein, ich kann einfach
Ich kann einfach den Stream zweimal aufmachen
Okay
Das ist broken, Leute
RIP
Zweimal starten im gleichen Browser geht nicht
Aber
Wir sind ja nice Hacker, man
Wir machen jetzt einfach in Chrome auf
Und in Chrome kann ich es bestimmt nochmal starten
Wie auch nicht?
Da, in Chrome kann ich es nochmal starten
Lulwi
Oder?
Oder Paintschamp?
Postchamp, Postchamp
Aber das geht noch, oder?
Ja
Okay
Was auch immer
Vielleicht kann man nicht mehr als 3 Verbindungen oder so machen
Kann ja sein
Sticky Window, die dann auf jedem Workspace zu sehen
Wirklich?
Ja, du meinst diese, du meinst diese
Ähm
Scratchpad Dinger
Echt, wirklich?
Oh, nice, nice, zeige ich mal her
Das müssen wir jetzt gerade mal ausprobieren
Sticky
Ne, ähm
Ne, wie hieß das, wie hieß das andere? Stack?
Also bei mir ist
Stacking
Stacking brauche ich eh nicht
Und jetzt Sticky?
Wirklich, geht das?
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
Also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt dieses Fenster hier nehme und sage
Windows S
Ach ne, Layout weg
Sticky Toggle
Okay
Und wenn ich jetzt dieses Fenster nehme
Sag Picture in Picture
Und sage jetzt Windows
Windows S
Boah, alter
Massive Braintier
Ist das das ja geil
Richtige Hacker, man, guckt euch das mal an
Boah, ist das Poker
Ist ja besser als OBS Layout
Der Chat ist wieder too smart für die Welt
Aber die Leute haben einfach gesubt
Das ist der High IQ
Der ist nur möglich gewesen durch
Wie viele Subs habe ich denn eigentlich aktuell?
Zeig mal
Ich bin ein bisschen runter gegangen in dem Monat
Aber ich glaube es ist immer noch relativ viel
321, ja
Guck mal
Es gab 321 mal IQ um 1
Plus 1
Danke schön für den Twitch Prime Sub
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt im Durchschnitt
Wenn man davon ausgeht, Durchschnitts IQ ist 100
Haben wir jetzt 421 IQ
Da kann man solche Sachen schon mal drauf kommen
Der Keks ist ein 3D
Das da
Der da, das ist ein 3D gedruckter Keks
So sieht es aus
Turbo Dead End
Subben
Und dann Instant Prüfung bestehen
So ist es
Genau
So sieht es aus
Also, ich habe mir dieses Case hier gekauft
Und wir werden jetzt das folgende machen
Das was wir schon mal gemacht haben
Und zwar, wir flashen jetzt in Raspberry Pi
Mit
Einen ordentlichen SSD diesmal
Ich habe hier schon, guckt mal
Einen Zipf SSD liegen
Big Brain SSD
Samsung
Hallo, kann man das vielleicht mal irgendwie ordentlich dahin
Samsung Endurance SSD
64G
Leute, ich glaube ich spiegel mich auf der SD
MonkaS
Beste, beste Mikro SD
Hast du noch was mit den Mikrotiks gebastelt?
Ja, da steht, da guck
Den verwenden wir heute als Switch für den Raspberry Pi
Ja, ich sag manchmal Mikro SD
Und SSD
Verwechsel ich manchmal ein bisschen
Aber ihr wisst was ich meine
Hier Chat
Massive
Also die sind wirklich nice
Oh es ruckelt
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Die verwenden wir heute
Ich pack die mal kurz aus
Eigentlich müssen wir da gar nicht ins Vollscreen schalten
Oder?
Wenn ich die Dinger auspacke sieht man doch wenn es klein ist
Genauso
Und außerdem ihr müsst mir nicht beim auspacken zugucken
Wer hat eigentlich
Kann man das eigentlich vergrößern?
Boah
Alter ist das big brain
Das ist ja massive
Huge
Guckt euch das mal an
Oh jetzt hat es geruckelt
Was für ein geiles Zeug
Mein Problem ist
Ich hab keine Schere
Meinung zu Linux Mindia kann man verwenden
Also was ich ja nicht verstehe ist
Warum, wenn man
Mikro SD Karten verpackt
Ähm
Warum macht man da nochmal
Ne Plastik
Ne Plastik Layer dazwischen
Das man das nicht einfach aufreißen kann
Was haben die sich denn da überlegt
Man kann den Scheiß nicht
Das geht nicht
Man kann den nicht aufreißen weil da ist noch so ein Plastik Layer dazwischen
Also ich weiß gar nicht
Wie man das eigentlich offiziell
Aufmacht wenn nicht mit der Schere
Weil man kann das irgendwie auseinanderreißen
Aber das sagt doch alles
Das muss man eigentlich mit einer Schere ausschneiden
So
Diebstahlschutz
Äh
Das ist kein Diebstahlschutz
Man muss das aufschneiden
Anders kriegt man das nicht auf
Die haben sogar hier extra
Sowas eingeblendet
Wo man aufschneiden muss
So jetzt hol ich mal die olle Schere von der Oma
Excellent
Das ist auch übelste Verschwendung finde ich
Das bei jeder Micro SD Karte
Dieses Ding hier dabei ist
Dieser Adapter
Der ist auch total useless
Wie findest du das neue Lied von Flair
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen
Ich hab noch nicht ein Lied von Flair gehört
Also
Die einzigen deutschen Hip Hop Sachen
Die ich kenne
Das sind ein paar Sachen von Haftbefehl
Äh
Das ist auch gut ein bisschen
Wie gesagt
Goethestraße Louis Vuitton Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar
Fick auf Sponsor
Einzige deutsche Rap Quote
Was ich kann
Money Boy
Kenn ich auch
Die ein oder anderen Sachen
Aber ich mag absolut keinen Hip Hop
Für mich ist gerade deutschsprachiger Hip Hop
Und generell so
Das einzige internationale Hip Hop Zeug
Was ich mir tatsächlich gut geben kann
So richtiger Hip Hop Fan
War ich noch nie
Und für mich ist
Wahrscheinlich sind jetzt wieder übelst viel offended
Weil es ist ja modern offended zu sein
Ähm
Für mich ist Hip Hop
Übelste Low Brain Musik
Also wenn der Sub
IQ++ gibt
Gibt jedes Hip Hop Lied IQ-
Minus
Empfiehlst du immer noch C Sharp
Als beste Programmiersprache
Weil C Sharp prinzipiell die beste Programmiersprache ist
Ich sag das C Sharp meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache ist
Und
Ähm
Sie ist halt
Super für alle möglichen Anwendungen
Ja und übrigens
Hip Hop ist das C++ der Musik
Ja das kommt ungefähr hin
Das triffts
Das triffts eigentlich ganz gut
Dis Abo nicht De Abo Leute
Als richtig krasser Gangster Rapper Hörer
Nicht De Abo
Ähm
Wann machst du wieder Stream zusammen mit Elotricks
Ja wir streamen ja auch sonst so oft zusammen
Es ist jetzt wirklich mal an der Zeit
Dass wir wieder zusammen streamen
Ähm
Was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen
Empfiehlst du
Wartet mal Chat ich wollte
Beste Möglichkeit
Beste Möglichkeit eine SSD festzuhalten
Also wenn ihr was braucht
So irgendwie zum schieren
Bei irgendeinem Sport Ereignis oder so
Und winkt mit der Mikro SD
So
Also was wollte ich jetzt sagen
Moment Chat ganz aus dem Konzept gebracht
Also
Siehste das habe ich ganz vergessen
Vielleicht wollte ich noch ein bisschen
Deutschrap flamen ich weiß es nicht
Ist auch egal
Äh aber zu der Frage von
Von Gunni
Gunde also
Wie gesagt C Sharp ist meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache
Das heißt nicht das das die beste Programmiersprache
Für alles ist
Der Vorteil ist wenn du C Sharp lernst
Das du warum ruckelt denn das zwischendurch
Was ist denn das hier was soll das
Leute habt ihr das gerade gesehen
Übertragungs der Übertragungschamp
Funktioniert nicht
Wlanchamp ist am abkacken
Also das schöne an C Sharp
Ist wenn du C Sharp gelernt hast
Du kannst damit mehr oder weniger alles machen was du machen willst
Das ist halt nice
Na
Du kannst von Serveranwendungen
Bis äh
C Sharp Anwendungen
Bis ziemlich Low Level Geschichten Audio Video Desktop Krams
Mobile Krams
Wobei Mobile Krams wäre nicht unbedingt meine erste Wahl
Kannst du mit C Sharp alles machen das ist halt schön
Und das finde ich gibt es so in dieser Form
Bei keiner anderen Sprache
Gerade die Möglichkeit
Für Windows Desktop haben wir
Also für Windows Desktop ist es einfach das beste was es gibt
Windows Desktop ist
Ziemlicher Rotz Windows Desktop Anwendungen zu machen
Aber wenn dann mit C Sharp
Dogecoin ist die Zukunft
Die habe ich auch schon gehört
Das ist kein Netzteil
Das ist ein Switch da oben
Das ist Manjaro mit I3 WM
Das Beste zum C Sharp Lernen
Ja so paar Kurse sind nicht verkehrt
Aber was ich empfehle immer
Wenn man einfach mal
Einen Einstieg sucht
Ist das hier
Das da
Das ist zwar
Visual Studio
C Sharp 2012
Das ist nicht wirklich aktuell
Aktuell ist .NET Core 5
Aber wenn du Kapitel 1
Bis Kapitel
Inklusive Kapitel 16
Den Rest kannst du vergessen
Das brauchst du nicht
Dann hast du schon mal eine ganz gute Übersicht
Über so die absoluten Basics
Und wir wissen ja alle
Ich muss es nicht sagen Leute
Mit was man anfängt
Das ist nicht verkehrt
Ansonsten gibt es so viele Webcasts
Tutorial Videos und alles mögliche auf Youtube
Da kommt man auch an Start
Und im Zweifelsfall
Kann man sich auch irgendeinen Kurs kaufen
Aber da kann ich dir nichts empfehlen
Hast du C Sharp beim Physik gelernt?
Nein ich konnte das vorher schon
Auf der Arbeit musst du ABAP
Ernsthaft?
Es gibt Leute die ernsthaft ABAP machen müssen
Moment oder war ABAP das SAP Zeug
War das dieses SAP
War das diese SAP Krempel da
Ne mit Java
Kannst du zum Beispiel keine schönen Windows Desktop Anwendungen machen
Du kannst mit Java
Desktop oder generell GUI Anwendungen machen
Aber die sind so ein bisschen
Java Style halt
Aber Java kommt in die Richtung
Wobei Java
Weiß ich nicht ob man
IOS Apps mitmachen kann
Na klar mit Elotrix zusammen
Warzone auf geht's Leute
Ja das ist auch so ein 3D Drucker das Logo
F Sharp kenne ich ja
Kenne ich aber nicht gut aus
SAP
Ok
Findest du PowerShell?
Ziemlich gut
Aber nicht als interaktive Shell
Für Automatisierung ist PowerShell cool
Ne IOS ist nicht
Only Swift und C Sharp
Das mag zwar die Native Geschichte sein
Aber meiner Meinung nach die einfachste Variante für Mobile Apps
Sind entweder Flutter
Oder sowas wie Ionic
Einfach Javascript
Quasi Elektron für Mobile
Dann hast du eine App für alles zusammen
Max wie lange muss man programmieren lernen
Um damit Geld verdienen zu können?
Das kann man nicht in Zeit messen
So aber
Also bevor ich jetzt hier lange rum laufe
Ich kann jetzt ja gleich mit euch weiter labern
Ich flash mal die SSD
Äh die Micro SD
Warum sag ich immer SSD
Und warum ist da eigentlich immer dieses komische
Adapter dabei
Hier
Dieser komische Adapter wozu
Ich hab also von diesen Adaptern
Ohne Scheiß Leute
Hab ich bestimmt
Da auch viel mehr aussieht
Okay
Guckt euch das mal an
Aufreiß Champ
Das ist alles das
Für so viel Inhalt
Ist natürlich
Gerechtfertigt
Also klar
Excellent
So dann flashen wir das erstmal
Schenk das den Leuten
Die du nicht magst zum Geburtstag
Ich bevorzug Leute die ich nicht mag
Zu ignorieren
Kontakt mitzutreten und denen schon gar nichts zum Geburtstag
zu schenken. So, wir flashen das mal
nebenbei. Also, wie gesagt, wenn es noch
was gibt, Chat, schießt los.
Kann ich jetzt noch
beantworten. Wir haben ja noch Zeit,
während das flasht.
Wenn ich die, wenn ich das reinbekomme.
Hallo? So, schauen wir mal.
Wir hatten den Kram runtergeladen.
Ich lasse das jetzt mal oben eingeblendet.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz nice. Hallo, Chat.
Du kannst die Adapter auf der Gamescom
raushauen. Ja, da müsste ich auf die Gamescom gehen.
Ich habe gehört,
ich habe gehört, auf der Gamescom kopiert man sich
Fastpasse. Fast
Passes. Nicht zu
verwechseln mit DSL Fast
Path. Hat jemand
eine gute, hat jemand eine gute
ähm
so ein Organizer
für Micro-SDs?
Samsung Pro Endurance, beste.
Grüße an Isle of Cookies.
Ja. Ich habe mit
ihm danach telefoniert und ich habe noch ein paar
Sachen erfahren dazu. Die sage ich jetzt aber
nicht im Stream, weil
erstens könnten da manche Leute Ärger kriegen und ich
vielleicht auch. Keine Ahnung. Ich will da keinem auf
die Füße treten. Wir haben danach
telefoniert nochmal und was
da wieder für Dinger gelaufen sind, Alter.
Oh, ich weiß schon, warum ich mit diesem ganzen
YouTube-Deutschland-Crap nichts mehr zu tun
habe, ey. Ja gut, aber den
da, also mal ernsthaft, Leute, also
den Keks da, den
den findet ihr nicht auf Thingiverse.
Es sei denn, irgendjemand hat meinen Keks
nachgebaut und auf Thingiverse gestellt. Der da
ist, äh, Maxors
Exclusive. So, wo haben wir denn hier
jetzt uns das aktuelle Raspberry Pi? Ich habe es doch
letztens erst runtergeladen.
Raspberry Pi OS
Booster. Da ist es, Booster.
Ich meine,
Leute, wir machen was anderes.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Wir flashen aktuelles Ubuntu
drauf, weil Ubuntu 64-bit,
da kann ich mehr Heat generaten.
Äh,
VCG Gen, ist das,
ist das, gibt es das unter Ubuntu?
Weil das, weil das, das wäre, das wäre,
das wäre wichtig. Damit kann man
nämlich die Temperatur auslesen vom Raspberry Pi.
Na, hat Windows,
ja, genau.
Okay, ich glaube, wir bleiben doch beim offiziellen
Raspbian.
Gibt es bei Ubuntu, okay.
Weil, weil hier sieht es nicht so aus, als
gibt es das. Okay, wir probieren
es jetzt einfach mal aus. Easy.
Ich zeige euch mal was Cooles, wenn ihr, wenn ihr, äh,
Arch habt oder Manjaro habt.
Da gibt es so einen, so einen
Tool, den Raspberry Pi Imager.
Ist eigentlich viel praktischer als mit,
mit Etcher jedes Mal den Kram zu machen.
Du kannst einen Node-Exporter draufschmeißen.
Wenn der das ohne diesen Kram auslesen kann,
ja, dann kann ich das machen.
Guck mal. Und jetzt starten wir das Ding.
Raspberry Pi Imager.
Und das ist viel angenehmer, als den Kram
jedes Mal runterzuladen und zu flashen.
Choose OS, sagen wir einfach
anderes OS, äh, ne,
anderes OS, Ubuntu,
und dann nehmen wir,
64-bit, 20.2,
10, ARM64.
Bam. Choose SD-Card.
Okay.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das hat er.
Choose SD. Wie ernsthaft,
das erkennt er nicht noch. Oh Gott.
MonkaS.
Three-Hat-Programm, Alter.
What the fuck?
Wer ist er doch?
Oi, mate, oi.
Äh.
Erkennt der,
erkennt der die SD-Karte grad nicht?
Okay, Leute.
Großer Nintendo-Trick.
Who's champ?
Warum erkennt der denn jetzt nix?
Der erkennt die,
der erkennt die Micro-SD-Karte nicht.
But why?
Was ist des?
Ey, okay,
jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Was, wisst ihr was wir probieren?
Wir probieren jetzt diesen Kack-Adapter aus,
ob er's damit erkennt.
Der krümelt.
Zwei Monat, dankeschön.
Ich hab noch irgendwo einen anderen SD-Karten.
Wartet mal.
Fuck, den hab ich schon ewig
nicht mehr verwendet, weil ich nicht
weiß nicht wo der ist.
Ich hab irgendwo noch einen anderen SD-Karten-Laser.
Liegt der hier oben vielleicht?
Nee.
Oi.
Hm.
Ich hab den, ich hab letztens,
ich hab ihn letztens irgendwo gesehen.
Ist er hier?
Hm.
Hier ist er nicht.
Wartet mal, ich guck mal kurz hier neben.
Ob der hier neben liegt?
SD-Karten-Champ?
Nee.
Ist der Cam Link?
Link?
Aber kein SD-Karten-Laser.
Na gut, ich mein, der Kram wird schon funktionieren.
So.
Ich mach's jetzt mal raus.
Und jetzt nehmen wir mal,
jetzt nehmen wir mal diesen,
diesen Müll hier und gucken ob wir das da irgendwie,
warum muss denn das da rein?
Erstmal abputzen.
Und schön drauf fingern.
So. Zack. Probieren wir mal, ob's so funktioniert.
What the?
Okay Leute, ich reboote mal.
Ich mein, prinzipiell erkennt er den Kram ja.
Was?
USB Disconnect?
Hat er das jetzt nicht durchgereicht?
Warum erkennt er diese Karte da drin nicht?
Was ist das schon wieder für ein Crap?
Ist die SD-Karte wirklich im Arsch?
Komm, lass mal unter Windows gucken.
Lass mal unter Windows gucken.
Was ist das?
Wie?
Keck Wait?
Unter Windows erkennt das?
Äh.
Jetzt bin ich aber ratlos.
Nee, nee, am Formatieren
kann das nicht liegen.
Der muss das,
der muss das ja erkennen als SD-Karte.
What the hell?
Warum, was ist denn das?
Was für eine Kacke.
Okay, Leute. Reboot. Easy.
Nee, nee, die verschwindet
ja unter Windows, wenn man die unter Linux
mountet.
Würde ich jetzt, wüsste ich
jetzt, wo mein anderer Micro-SD-Karten-
Reader ist, ne?
Dann könnte ich den auch, könnte ich's
mal ausprobieren, aber
ich hab echt keinen Plan,
wenn ich hier so am Schreibtisch rumguck.
Sind zwar Geräte da, die sehr ähnlich aussehen,
aber der Micro-SD-Kartenleser ist nicht
da. Mal mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob's jetzt geht nach dem Reboot.
Leute, das ist doch noch,
hat doch mit Dateisystem überhaupt nichts zu tun,
wenn er das Device nicht mal findet.
Chat.
Cag wait.
Wenn er noch nicht mal das, das, das, das Gerät
an sich erkennt, dann
ist es, das ist noch ein Schritt
vor Filesystem.
Ha, da ist er.
Easy. Reboot.
Einfach, Leute. Einfach rebooten. Easy.
Alles gut, alles, alles
geregelt. Einfach, einfach
rebooten.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Okay, Champ.
So, jetzt, jetzt können wir endlich das machen,
was ich eigentlich machen will. Also,
OS auswählen.
Ist die Musik ein bisschen laut heute?
Dicken, Dicken laut vielleicht.
Bisschen leiser.
Reboot-Champ. Hat, hatte ich
irgendein Kernel-Update gestern noch gemacht?
Ach, was auch immer. Man weiß es nicht.
Aber,
sagen wir mal so, ne,
auch mit Kernel-Update sollte eigentlich ein USB,
ist wurscht. So, zack.
Ähm,
Ubuntu
64-bit, Server OS.
Jawoll.
Choose SD-Card. Da ist es.
64G. Right.
Yes.
So, man sieht, die Dinger sind jetzt auch
ein bisschen schneller.
Die sind jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller als die andere
SD-Karte. Ja.
Der muss auch nebenbei
runterladen.
Welches Case? Nein.
Dieses Case hier.
Da steht es ja schon drauf.
The most beautifully
crafted Raspberry Pi 4
Case. Und wenn der
Hersteller das sagt, wissen wir ja
prinzipiell, dass das immer stimmt.
Hat uns jemals ein Hersteller schon angelogen?
Kommt nie vor.
Die Hersteller sagen
aus Prinzip immer die Wahrheit.
Sixteen times
the detail.
So, jetzt kann ich mal ein bisschen Chat gucken,
wenn das flasht.
Also.
Muss der das Image bei jedem
Start neu runterladen?
Ne, ich glaub, der cached sich das irgendwo.
Wie sieht denn das Case aus?
So.
Passiv gekühlt.
Wir packen das gleich aus, aber erstmal muss ich den Raspberry Pi flashen.
So, ich scroll jetzt mal kurz
den Chat durch, ob ich irgendwas vergessen hab.
Zu beantworten, während der
hier am flashen ist.
Also Chat, ich muss euch sagen,
ich verstehe euren Reflex,
wenn was nicht geht,
den Self dazu zu geben.
Den gleichen
Reflex hab ich auch immer, wenn irgendwas nicht
geht. Aber es wär schön,
wenn ihr manchmal ein bisschen langsamer wärt.
Weil
manche Sachen ergeben keinen Sinn.
Zum Beispiel,
wenn man erst das Device nicht sieht,
braucht man sich um das Filesystem
keine Gedanken machen. Aber trotzdem,
Big Brain Chat, wie immer.
Max Ward plus Champ, ja.
Slow Champ.
Has been written.
Okay, nice.
Continue.
Zack. Und jetzt das allerwichtigste,
was man sowohl unter
Ubuntu als auch unter Raspbian machen muss.
Ja, 30 FPS
vor allem ist eindeutig zu wenig.
Viel, viel zu wenig.
Man muss den Kram mounten.
Ich hab's bestimmt noch in der History.
Mount, SDB mounten.
Oder halt da, wo eure SD-Karte ist.
Touch SSH.
Und am besten
könnt ihr euch nicht einloggen drauf.
Sucked.
So, gut. Dann
kann man die SD-Karte rausziehen.
Zack.
Und können jetzt
das Ganze
mal in Raspberry Pi stecken
und gucken, ob da alles startet.
Machen wir das hier mal weg.
Oh, da ist noch das alte drin.
Das leg ich mal hier oben in so ein Fach,
dass ich's wieder finde.
Und mir fällt grad auf,
ich hab kein Netzwerkkabel.
Oder doch?
Oder hab ich die draußen alle im Schrank?
Wartet mal, ich werd hier doch irgendwo,
ohne dass ich jetzt rausgehen muss,
noch ein Netzwerkkabel rumfliegen
haben, was ich nicht brauche.
Hm.
Ich hab aufgeräumt.
Manchmal hat das echt seine Nachteile,
wenn man aufräumt.
Wenn man aufräumt, ist danach nichts mehr da.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr dieses Phänomen kennt.
Das ist wie, wenn man Unreal Tournament
spielen will.
Da will man ja auch nicht, dass es lädt.
Nee, ich hab kein Netzwerkkabel
mehr hier. Ich hab alles aufgeräumt.
Top.
Ordnungs-Champ.
Bin sofort wieder da.
WLAN will ich in dem Fall jetzt erstmal
nicht haben. So, ich hab das längste
Netzwerkkabel aller Zeiten geholt.
Also, ich glaub, ein viel
kürzeres Netzwerkkabel
werdet ihr nicht finden.
Miniatur-Netzwerkkabel.
Aber ich mein,
für unsere Zwecke,
wenn man das jetzt mal ein bissl
auseinanderkriegt,
irgendwie.
Für unsere Zwecke soll das hier ausreichen.
Zack. So.
Was darf's sein?
Welcher Port?
Acht oder so.
Eher vier. Vier.
Optimal-Port.
Optimaler PogChamp-Port.
So, ähm,
ein paar Netzteile ist hier.
Dann schließen wir das jetzt mal an.
So ein bisschen, sodass man das irgendwie gescheit sieht.
So, und dann
gucken wir mal, ob wir uns einloggen können.
So, da muss jetzt eh erstmal die Festplatte,
äh, nicht die Festplatte, die Micro-SD-Karte
musste jetzt hier erstmal irgendwie
macht der was? Ja.
Erstmal
resizen und alles mögliche.
Seht ihr eigentlich das, seht ihr?
Wartet mal.
Seht ihr, dass der Link aktiv ist?
Erkennt man das? Ja, das sieht man, ne?
Vielleicht müsste ich den Switch noch ein bisschen...
Wartet mal.
Vielleicht mach ich den Switch noch ein
bisschen hoch, dass man die Ports
die Ports
besser erkennt.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Weil ich hab mir überlegt,
das Setup so ist eigentlich ziemlich praktisch.
Du hast hier den Switch, du hast hier
neben die Steckdosenleiste und hier
kannst du alles machen drauf. Und ich muss
es nicht rumlaufen, das steht jetzt direkt am Fenster.
Ich muss, ich muss eigentlich gar nichts machen
im Endeffekt. Das ist ganz, ganz nützlich.
So, besser jetzt? Erkennt man
es jetzt besser? Jetzt erkennt man noch
besser, dass der Link an ist, oder?
Ja, macht keinen großen Unterschied.
So. Exquisite.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob wir Verbindung zum Raspberry Pi
bekommen. Schieben wir das mal ein bisschen,
machen wir das mal ein bisschen klein.
Das ist, nee, das ist kein
SFP Plus Modul, das ist ein
Direct Attached Kabel.
Du meinst das da, ne? Hier.
Den da.
Das ist ein 7 Meter Direct Attached Kabel.
Das geht hinter in den Serverraum.
So.
Wait a minute.
Hat er den Raspberry Pi nicht erkannt?
Doch, hier.
Kann das Ding auch 7 Millionen Megaflips
Paintschamp, Paintschamp
Choke. Also,
SSH, Copy ID,
Ubuntu,
ich glaube, Ubuntu ist das Standard-Login.
Yes.
Ubuntu, Ubuntu, irgendwie so war es
das Passwort, glaube ich.
Äh.
Oder war es Ubuntu-Leer?
Oh, ne, was war, oder war es Ubuntu-Passwort?
Ach, man musste sich
erst mal einloggen. Das ist, das ist,
nee, nee, das ist Lowbrain-Ubuntu-Taktik.
Man muss sich erst einmalig einloggen
und ein neues Passwort vergeben
und dann kann ich das Passwort deaktivieren.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt geht das.
Richtig, richtig,
richtig Lowbrain.
Moment.
Wo ist mein Ubuntu-E-Mode?
Findest du nicht?
Lowbrain-Jubantu.
Ja, da sind wir am Start.
Das Ganze ist jetzt deutlich schneller
mit dieser SD-Karte,
mit dieser Micro-SD-Karte als mit der anderen.
Wir hätten auch die,
wir hätten auch die SSD nehmen können.
So, und jetzt gucken wir erst mal, wie warm das Ganze wird.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal,
ob das stimmt, ob der Chat recht hat.
Der Chat meinte nämlich,
VC Gen ist
auf Ubuntu vorhanden.
Das war nur der Sound.
Wieso ist das feste IP-Adressen
vergeben an ein Raspberry Pi
per SSH? So, kennst du das?
Ist das gar nicht Raspberry Pi Config
und gut ist?
VC Gen ist nicht drauf.
Chat.
Wer hat mich gebetet?
Achso.
Na, aber VC Gen, CMD ist auch nicht drauf.
Ah, man kann es aber nachinstallieren.
Okay, nur halb gebetet.
Nur halb gebetet.
Ich will aber keinen Node-Exporter da drauf
jetzt installieren und danach irgendwie im Grafana
einrichten oder sonst was.
Ich will einfach die Temperatur auslesen.
Kann Zensors das eigentlich auch?
Kann LNSensors das eigentlich auch?
Ne, von Kryptowährungen habe ich keine
großartige Ahnung.
Okay, VC Gen, CMD und jetzt, äh,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die
Temperature, Measure Temp.
Okay.
Measure Temp. Excellent. Also,
CPU,
CPU ist
48 Grad.
Stress, Suspense. So.
Und jetzt waren wir mal busy.
Busy Temperatur auf dem Ding.
Hallo, Chat.
Das sieht voll,
das sieht voll Three Head aus,
wenn ich winke und nur die halbe Hand drin ist.
Das sieht anders aus, als hätte ich
keinen Anfall oder so.
Das sieht voll kaputt aus.
Hast du noch Passivkühler?
Ne, das machen wir mit dem aktuellen Gehäuse.
Das, also aktuell habe ich gar nichts.
Ich habe, guckt hier.
Massive Brain Chat.
Hier, gar nichts drauf.
Absolut nackig.
Xeroxine und Dankeschön für den Sub.
Warum benutzt du
T-Max? Weil es besser ist.
Weil du da so Big Brain Sachen machen kannst
wie Splitten oder so und dann wieder
reinzoomen und rauszoomen
und Zeug.
Und du kannst relativ easy sharen,
was bei Screen auch geht, aber nicht so einfach ist.
So.
Ähm.
Watch, was war das?
VC, GEN, CMD, Measure,
Mea, Sure, Temp.
So, und wie sagt man bei Watch nochmal die Zeit,
wie er aktualisieren soll? N?
Ah, yes.
So, Hardtop.
Gucken wir uns mal an, wie die Auslastung ist.
So, okay.
Wir machen mal ein bisschen Temperatur.
Stress.
Minus Minus CPU 8.
Ne, CPU 4.
Und jetzt bin ich sicher, wie es weitergeht.
Ähm.
Also, wir machen Stress, Leute.
Temperatur geht rauf.
100% CPU Auslastung.
Hat der Raspberry Pi
irgendeine Art von,
keine Ahnung,
Hyperthreading oder sowas?
Lohnt sich das mehr als
4 Threads zu starten?
Welches Case testen wir?
Aktuell ist noch gar kein Case dran,
aber wir testen dieses hier.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach
beste Case, was es so gibt.
Sowohl von der Verarbeitung her,
als auch von der Optik, als auch
vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Nummer 1 bei der Kühlleistung, aber ausreichend.
So, also es wird ordentlich warm.
Soll ich mal
draufgreifen, Leute?
Echt, kann man das direkt auslesen?
Das ist natürlich auch nice.
Oh!
Alter!
Das ist heiß as fuck!
Also, ob das
nur 63 ist, ich weiß...
Au!
Das ist richtig heiß!
Die Argon Dinger sind richtig gut, das stimmt,
aber die sind größer und die sind,
finde ich, fast schon ein bisschen zu teuer.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt
noch bräuchten?
So eine Wärmebildkamera,
die das erkennt, wie warm es ist.
Oder wir müssten
uns einen ESP32
machen, mit
einem Temperatursensor,
so einem DS20
bla, wie auch immer.
Ich kann einen Sysbench machen,
ja, und den dann da drauf
kleben. Okay,
das wird echt warm jetzt.
Okay,
mach ich. Ich mach genau das
Kommando, was du geschickt hast.
Wird ja nicht allzu lange dauern.
Ah, siehste? Grip. Geht schon mal
mit. Chat schickt Kommandos,
die nicht funktionieren. Muss man da
4 machen? 3 hat Chat.
Hast du ihn übertaktet?
Ne, das können wir gleich noch machen.
Das können wir gleich noch machen.
Der Sysbench ist installiert.
Run. Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Hier, dann lassen wir mal kurz Sysbenchen.
Es gibt, glaube ich, schon eine Wasserkühlung.
Doch, ich glaube, es gibt mittlerweile
eine Wasserkühlung.
Es gibt auch mehr Subscriber.
Ja, immer. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch schon
erzählt habe, dass wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account
habt, dass ihr kostenlos einmal
im Monat einen Streamer eurer Wahl
unterstützen könnt auf Twitch.
So, hier, hast du deine Ausgabe,
deine Sysbench-Ausgabe?
Exquisite.
So, und jetzt machen wir nochmal Stress.
Und danach übertakten wir ihn nochmal.
Ja, kann man machen. Also,
selbst ausdrucken ist auch eine Variante. Allerdings
aus einem 3D-Drucker kriegst du ja keine
wärmeleitenden Gehäuse raus, ne. Also, kann man machen.
Keine Metallgehäuse.
Wie lang Stress?
So lange, bis sich die Temperatur nicht mehr nennenswert verändert.
Also, das letzte Mal sind wir, glaube ich,
hoch auf, frag mich nicht, 78 Grad
oder so gekommen. Mit dem letzten
Pi 4, bevor wir es ins Gehäuse gebaut haben.
In ein anderes Gehäuse, nicht in das Gehäuse.
Das Gehäuse
hatten wir im Stream noch nicht.
Aber jetzt lassen wir ihn erstmal
ordentlich
Temperatur voll. Und dann übertakten
wir ihn. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das ging. Ich glaube,
config.txt
Monster360 abonniert
Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
MassiveSubIQ++
Dankeschön für die Subscription.
Sellout hat gewirkt. Ja, ab und zu muss man
ein bisschen Sellout machen.
Pi Overclock. Ich glaube, man muss
irgendwas in config.txt schreiben.
Ich hab, das ist Ubuntu drauf.
Ich hab kein Config.
Also, ich hab kein Config oder sowas.
Kann man das nachinstallieren? Ne.
Übertakten jetzt.
Also, hier.
Config.
Excellent.
Das in der Config übertakten geht in der
Aber angeblich geht das hier.
Wie sieht man die Clock Speed?
Das ist doch einfach nur
Ach, hier Frequency.
Hier Frequency.
Salken21, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, boot config.
Ne, warte mal. Wo liegt das Ding?
Moment, wo?
Config.
Okay, wait.
Die gibt's bei mir gar nicht.
Okay, da müssen wir mal suchen.
Ubuntu Overclock Pi 4.
Tja, Killcard,
du musst das so schreiben, dass ich sehe.
Jetzt hab ich's zufällig mal
gesehen.
Aber wenn die Fragen nicht explizit an mich
gehen, dann sehe ich die nicht.
Okay, wie übertaktet man da?
Man kann die Datei vielleicht einfach anlegen.
Hast du aktuell schon
einen neuen Job? Wenn ja, wo, wenn man fragen darf?
Ich hab keinen neuen Job.
Ich hab immer noch den gleichen Job.
Overvoltage.
Bam. Okay, Leute.
Wir...
Wir übertakten jetzt.
config.txt
Und einfach
jetzt diesen Kram da rein.
Okay, wir übertakten jetzt von
Wir übertakten jetzt
von 1500 MHz auf
2000 MHz.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Mal gucken, ob das so funktioniert.
Und wir overvolten
auch.
Nexonus, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das YouTube-Kündigungsvideo. Ja, ich weiß nicht
wie weit
du es geguckt hast,
aber in dem YouTube-Kündigungsvideo
erzähl ich nicht von meinem aktuellen
Job, sondern dort, wo ich meine
Ausbildung gemacht hab.
Und am Ende erzähl ich auch, dass ich
nach der Ausbildung dort gelandet bin, wo ich
jetzt bin. Exposed.
Okay, mal schauen,
ob das Übertakten dann nicht funktioniert.
Okay, wait.
Okay, vielleicht muss man Last verursachen.
Vielleicht muss man Last verursachen,
dass es funktioniert.
Stress. Stress.
Stress. Jawoll.
Bam. Nope.
Ich hab doch rebooted.
Geht nicht.
Übertakten not
possible.
Falscher Ordner? Echt?
Ne, oder?
Oh.
Keck wait.
Ups.
Äh.
User-Config?
Was zum Teufel ist User?
User-Config.
Frequency.
Okay, ich reboote nochmal.
Reboot.
Kann man das auch irgendwie mit
dem VC-Gen-Tool machen?
Die Musik ist übelst laut auf einmal, ne?
Ne, passt eigentlich.
Sollen wir mal gucken,
was der jetzt sagt?
Oh.
Startet der
jetzt nicht mehr, oder was?
Ah, da ist er wieder.
MonkaS. Dachte schon, er startet
nicht mehr, ey.
Das wär's jetzt echt gewesen.
Bam.
2 Gigahertz, jawoll. Wow.
6000 Gigahertz.
Nee, ach nee.
600 Megahertz nur noch. Alles klar.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir doch mal,
wie warm er jetzt wird.
Stress. Bam.
Temp.
Ja, ja, alles ausgelastet.
Oh ja, der wird schon ein bisschen wärmer jetzt, hä?
Wo ist ein Limit?
Leute. Ah.
Zählt das als Selbstverletzung
im Stream, wenn ich mich da jetzt verbrenne?
Werd ich dann gebannt?
Ah, Leute, das ist übelst heiß.
Hahaha.
Das
geht gut ab.
Okay, noch taktet er sich nicht runter.
Ähm.
Max-Temperatur.
Ja, und?
Was, was, was, ab wann taktet er sich runter?
83 Grad.
Also der Takt, also
anscheinend noch nicht.
Ah, über 85 Grad. Okay, über
85 Grad taktet er sich runter.
Das Flir-Case, ich hab's auf
Amazon bei einem Drittanbieter gekauft.
Ich kann jetzt aber leider nicht
genau sagen, für wieviel.
Guck mal.
Zeigt die Taktrate.
Ah, guck mal.
Jetzt vorbei, Leute.
Jetzt vorbei.
Jetzt wird's runter getaktet.
86 Grad.
Jetzt vorbei.
Ich weiß gar nicht. Ja, jetzt taktet er sich wieder hoch.
Guckt, er taktet sich hoch.
Und dann ab, ab jetzt
fängt er an, sich wieder runterzutakten.
Magfly, dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay, ich würd sagen, das ist
für Temperaturtest erstmal genug.
Oder wollen wir ihn noch ein Stückchen übertakten?
Wollen wir nochmal gucken, ob noch ein bisschen mehr
Wobei, wir
sind jetzt schon am Limit. Wir sind ja jetzt schon am Limit.
Ja. Wir sind ja jetzt schon komplett
Temperature-Limit.
Okay, ich würd sagen zum, zum
Das ist warm genug.
Nee, Raum-Over glaub ich nicht.
Okay, der, der kommt ans Temperatur-Limit.
Dann würd ich sagen, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal
das Gehäuse und bauen das Ding ein.
Und gucken mal.
Guck mal, der taktet sich auch direkt runter
dann. Wenn er, wenn er
an 85 Grad kommt.
Siehst du klar, direkt.
Okay.
Boah, Alter, das ist heiß.
Aber da kannst du fast ein Ei drauf
backen, ey. So, dann
schauen wir uns mal das Gehäuse an, würd ich sagen.
Ich switch mal
kurz rüber. Oder wisst ihr was?
Ich mach einfach Fullscreen.
Viel besser.
Ei backen. Der Chat
hat da schon wieder komische,
komische Ideen. Also.
Dann packen wir das doch mal
aus und gucken uns das an, ob das wirklich
das most beautiful
crafted Raspberry Pi
Case ist.
Überhaupt. Ja.
Schauen wir mal.
So, wie geht denn das hier raus?
So. Okay.
Schon mal ganz nice verpackt.
Wollen wir mal rein.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Haben wir das Case drin
und ansonsten nix.
Okay, das kann ich schon alles mal runterhauen.
Schmeiß ich mal alles hier auf die Erde. Brauchen wir nicht.
Hier ist das Case drin.
Da ist es.
Sieht recht unspektakulär aus.
Wir haben ein paar Schrauben.
Paar Schrauben.
Äh.
Ich denk mal das ist der Boden. Vermut ich mal.
Ja.
Und das ist das Teil.
Das Ding ist wirklich relativ massiv.
Weiß ich ob man das gut
hört. Pass mal auf.
Also da ist schon ein bisschen
Metall.
Das ist schon recht massiv das Ding.
Und das kommt auf die
CPU.
By the way, aus welchem Grund
hat denn das ein Loch hier drinnen?
Sollte das nicht besser
plan aufliegen und nicht hier ein Loch haben?
Wisst ihr was richtig pro wäre?
Hätte ich jetzt noch Wärmeleitpaste.
Hätte ich hier noch irgendwo
Wärmeleitpaste, das wäre mal
Massive Exquisite, oder?
Das ist kein Pad.
Oder ist da ein Pad dabei?
Wartet mal. Ah hier ist ein Pad dabei.
Guckt mal.
Aber ich glaub Wärmeleitpaste wäre cooler, oder?
Ich hab aber glaub, also ich hab
definitiv noch, aber ich hab ja wie gesagt
ich hab ja aufgeräumt.
Hahaha
Ähm
Ich, ich, Leute, ich kriech mal kurz
hier runter, da liegt nämlich noch eine Ikea-Tasche
mit ganz viel Kabeln drinnen.
Wo ich so die Überbleibsel,
die muss ich noch wegräumen, wo ich noch so die
Überbleibsel drin hab. Vielleicht
hab ich Glück, und da ist
noch ein bisschen Wärmeleitpaste drin.
Weil da sind
da sind ganz viele alte Sachen
drin, da könnte durchaus
noch ein bisschen
irgendwo Wärmeleitpaste
drin sein.
Die gute der Bauer, der Bauer-Wärmeleitpaste
ist das, die ich da hier am Start hatte.
Irgendwie
Thermal Grizzly
Conductor, ne nicht.
Conductor-Naut ist das Flüssigmetall gewesen.
Äh
Cryo-Naut oder so hieß das Ding.
Nope.
Nix dabei.
Schauen wir mal hier.
Ich grech grad ein bisschen auf die Erde rum.
Ah, ah
Was ist denn hier? Noctua, Noctua-Lüfter.
PogChamp, PogChamp, nein.
Beim Noctua-Lüfter wär die Chance gut gewesen,
dass es da irgendwo dabei wär.
Aber...
Ne.
Keine
Ikea-Tasche
hat keine Wärmeleitpaste für uns,
Leute.
Keine Wärmeleitpaste.
Ist das hier? Ist das hier?
Ah!
In your face!
Die gute Noctua-Wärmeleitpaste
ist das sogar.
Ich hab zwar irgendwo noch
die Thermal Grizzly gehabt, aber die tut's
auch, oder? Ist das nicht pock,
da ich noch mal so auf die Stelle ein bisschen Wärmeleitpaste
gefunden hab?
Guckt euch das mal an hier.
Und zwar ist das
Noctua NT H1.
Okay, wir können
das jetzt ja mal...
Deswegen sind Noctua-Lüfter auch so
teuer.
Hat das einen erkennbaren Unterschied? Wir... Leute,
wir können das erst mal probieren mit dem
Pad und dann mit der...
Was, mein Mikrofon knattert?
Saft?
Was knattert da?
Ich hab immer auf der Erde...
Ich bin eben auf der Erde rumgekrabbelt. Da kann's
durchaus sein, dass es knattert.
Ach so, ja, ja.
Ich bin eben auf der Erde rumgekrochen.
Ich würd erst mal
Paste machen, sonst brauchst du ein neues Pad.
Stimmt, ja.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das einen erkennbaren
Unterschied hat.
Das könnte natürlich sein.
Paste geht nicht wegen dem Abstand...
Oh, nee, ernsthaft?
Ah, fuck, oder?
Wartet mal.
Ja, ja.
Wir machen mal kurz ab.
Äh, Leute, ich...
Ich schalte den Raspberry Pi mal aus.
Hat ja keinen Sinn.
Wir müssen ja nicht am lebenden Patient
rumdoktern.
Ach so.
Das wär's wohl nicht, wenn ich grad das Netzwerkkabel
rausgezogen hab.
Keck, wait.
Ah, nee.
Okay, geht wieder. Alles klar.
Hat sich erholt.
Ich mach mal aus. Power off.
Wir können Paste, Pad, Paste machen.
Oh ja, für noch bessere Bindung.
Moin, was machst du mit dem Pi?
Ich teste, ob das Gehäuse taugt.
Ich hoffe mal, weil
optisch
und so von der
von der Quality fühlt sich das ja bisher
am besten an von allen Cases,
die ich so in der Hand hatte.
Also, für ein Pi.
Okay, ähm, jetzt probieren wir das mal aus.
Also, wenn ich den Kram hier draufsetze.
Machen wir mal ab. Hier machen wir auch ab.
Oh, das Ding. Ey, der ganze
Raspberry Pi ist ultra heiß
hier.
Nach der Burn-In-Session da.
So, das muss ja nämlich hier so rein.
So.
Und die Sache... Hups. Mach ich das überhaupt richtig?
Nein, so viel...
So viel verkehrt kann man da ja eigentlich nicht machen, ne?
Hier, so.
Oder doch?
Kann man da was verkehrt machen?
Keck, keck, wait.
Keck, keck, keck, wait. Warum?
Wait, wait a minute. Warum geht das nicht?
Äh, einfach mal drücken.
Ne.
Okay, oh Leute.
Big Brain Fingerfertigkeit sind jetzt gefragt.
Oh, please, Kamera groß. Stimmt, ja.
Das sollte ich vielleicht machen.
Big Brain Fingerfertigkeit
ist gefragt.
Wie kriegt man es richtig rein?
Ich würde sagen, man muss einfach ein bisschen...
Einfach ein bisschen drücken.
Hä? Ich meine...
Ah, guck mal hier. Hier raste...
Hier raste das dann ein. Man kann das, glaube ich, einfach
runterdrücken.
Ha, zack, easy.
Wow, ist drin.
Das Problem ist jetzt, ich habe
keine Ahnung, ob das aufliegt oder nicht.
Man sieht es ja nicht.
Also, also, kommt Leute, wir nehmen das Pad.
Wir nehmen das Pad. Scheiß auf...
Scheiß auf...
Scheiß auf Wärmeleitpaste, auch wenn wir die
Nice Noctua Wärmeleitpaste haben.
Wir sehen nicht, ob das aufliegt.
Und solange wir nicht sehen, ob das aufliegt,
dann hat es keinen Sinn.
Mach doch Dünnpaste und teste.
Hmm...
Dünnpaste und testen.
Wo mache ich denn die Paste am besten drauf?
Äh...
Wahrscheinlich am besten hier...
Äh, wie funzt denn das überhaupt?
Muss man das drehen?
Ah ja.
Macht das jetzt was?
So, äh, ich bräuchte noch
irgendeinen Spachtel oder sowas.
Ich bräuchte noch irgendwie so einen
Spachtel oder sowas, um das zu verteilen.
Vielleicht...
Warte mal, vielleicht war beim Noctua auch sowas
dabei gewesen.
Noctua Spachtel.
Ne.
Kein Noctua Spachtel.
Aber sowas hier.
Ähm, so.
Exquisite.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das ganze Kontakt hat.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich müsste ja...
Wenn es Kontakt hat, müsste ich es ja sehen.
Auf der CPU.
Was meint ihr? Meint ihr, das tut?
Meint ihr, das geht?
So, jetzt sollte ich eigentlich einen Fleck auf der CPU haben,
wenn es richtig drauf ist.
Nope.
Nope, zu großer Abstand.
Okay, Leute, äh, ich brauch mal ein Stück Klopapier.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Oder hab ich...hab ich hier irgendwie...
Geht auch.
Das von der Verpackung, das geht
genauso.
Exquisite Wärmeleitpaste verschmieren.
So muss das sein, jawoll.
Brauche ich eigentlich was ordentlich zum
Reinigen. Okay, sauber genug.
Zack, machen wir das Pad drauf.
Ja,
keine Küchenrolle da.
Keine Küchenrolle, sonst wenn ich irgendwas umschmeiß,
habe ich echt ein Problem.
Gut. Dann machen wir dieses
komische Pad drauf.
Ui, Tütenöffner.
Jetzt rächt sich's wieder, dass ich
absolut keine
Fingernägel hab.
So. Okay, also.
Ich würd sagen, wir pappen das
Wir pappen das auf
den...auf die CPU
drauf. Das ist besser.
Weil dann ist es auf jeden Fall zentriert, weil das Ding hier
ist größer. Oh, jetzt bräuchten
wir ein paar Grills mit
Fingernägel. So.
Excellent.
Ich muss noch den Kram da oben abmachen.
Okay, wunderbar.
Rein damit.
Kenji in 7 Monaten,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Hallo, jetzt
geht's nicht? Doch, jetzt.
Ey, what the?
What the fuck? Ich hatte es doch eben schon mal drin.
Was ist das für Threehead-Scheiß?
Threehead of Doom
ist das hier. Oh, das geht
nochmal rein. What the hell?
What? What? What? Warum?
Das ging doch eben schon mal. Ich hatte es doch eben schon
mal drin.
What the fuck?
Das ging doch eben easy as fuck rein.
Guck mal,
eben hatte ich einfach so.
Ah, okay.
Bisschen Gewalt braucht man an der Stelle einfach.
Sieht so aus.
So, und jetzt sollte das einst draufpappen.
Gut, dann machen wir jetzt noch die, die,
den Schraubchamp rein.
Passt das hier überhaupt?
Ja, passt.
Moment, den Schraubchamp macht man hier unten durch, ne?
Wo ist das jetzt?
So. So, für die
SSD, hm?
Ich würde sagen, ich würde sagen, das muss so drauf und die SSD
und die SSD muss da so durch.
Aber die
SSD mal raus.
So, hm? Also ich würde sagen,
so, so gehört's.
Anders geht's
ja auch nicht. Das schwarze ist
Plastik, ja.
Anders geht's ja auch nicht.
Hier passt die SSD noch rein.
Moment, ist falsch rum, ne?
So rum ist glaube ich richtig.
Nice, guck mal, die haben extra
schönes Loch hier
für die, ähm,
für die Micro-SD drin, ne?
Hier neben ist eine Aussparung, das ist
wahrscheinlich für die LEDs,
dass man sieht, wenn die LEDs angehen.
So, also, schreiben wir das mal.
Ja, ich sag immer SSD, obwohl es eigentlich
eine Micro-SD ist. Fragt mich nicht, warum.
Irgendwie tu ich mir schwer,
in meinem Boomer-Hirn,
Micro-SD
und SSD im Eifer des Gefechts
auseinanderzuhalten.
Micro-SSD, noch besser,
oder?
Nano-SSHD, ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Schraube, Schraube, Schraube.
Excellent.
So.
Gut.
Alles fest, sitzt passt.
Fühlt sich auch recht
hochwertig stabil
an.
Sitzt auch ziemlich gut,
was die Slots angeht.
Sehr ordentlich.
Hier, seht ihr das?
Hier hat das Gehäuse
eine Delle.
Oder so ein Loch, das ist nicht so gut.
Na gut.
Ich frag mich ja, ob die mal einen Raspberry Pi bauen,
der defaultmäßig
auch über PoE geht. Das wäre cool.
So, wenn die das richtig
gemacht haben, sollte man jetzt eigentlich
hier die LEDs
sehen. Guck mal mal.
Ja, guck mal, man sieht,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es seht. Seht ihr das?
Ja, ne?
Excellent.
Gut, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie warm das jetzt wird.
Schauen wir mal.
Ja, man kann mit so einem Adapter das
machen, der dann von PoE
auf den Strom geht, vom Raspberry
und so. Das habe ich schon gesehen, aber
einfach PoE anstöpseln und
geht, geht soweit ich weiß bei keinem
Raspberry Pi.
LED Champ, ja.
Gut.
Also.
Clock, Temp,
Stress.
Jetzt, jetzt schauen wir mal.
Okay, Auslastung ist wieder volle Pulle.
So, mal gucken,
wie es jetzt hochgeht. Was heißt
PoE? Äh, PoE ist Strom
übers, hier, Strom übers Netzwerkkabel.
Was, Jepp ist auch
weg? Jepp hatten wir nie
aktiviert. Jebaited.
Wir hatten Salami aktiviert.
Aber Salami war ja zu obszön.
Hm?
Okay, Gehäuse wird ein bisschen warm, Gehäuse wird ein bisschen
warm. Aber Leute,
es bleibt ja mal deutlich kühler.
Guckt mal, bei dem anderen war man mehr oder
weniger instant
am Limit. 85 Grad.
Ne, der kann,
der kann das nur, wenn du das passende
äh, PoE hat hast.
Der Raspberry Pi.
Da brauchst du so ein extra, so ein extra
Board für PoE.
Und dann geht das mit dem Raspberry Pi
3B+.
Aber einfach so out of the box
geht das nicht. So, also.
Temperatur ist absolut in Ordnung.
Gehäuse, Gehäuse wird
recht
ist lauwarm überall
jetzt, aber passt schon.
Passt, ist okay.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung.
DrMax kontrolliert
Temperatur.
Gut. Ich würd
sagen, wir müssen jetzt noch mal ein bisschen weiter übertakten,
oder?
Weil ich mein, einfach nur
bei 60
Grad bleiben, das kann's ja jetzt nicht sein.
Welches Case ist das
genau das da?
Flirg-Case.
Und aktuell gibt's das sogar
hier schon für
21,90.
Was ich finde ein recht guter, recht guter
Preis ist. Okay, es ist
weder das noch Chat at Price
Champ. Ich wollte eigentlich gucken, was der Versand
kostet, aber ich glaub der Versand ist mit Prime
in dem Fall auch kostenlos.
Kostenlose Lieferung, ja.
Wie groß ist der Rahmen? Der hat 4G.
4G.
Moment. Faltes Fenster.
Fast.
Ja, 4G.
Das Armor-Case. Ja, es gibt ein paar gute, das kenn ich
noch nicht.
Das Argon-Case ist auch ziemlich
gut.
Ja, das ist so ein
ganz günstiges. Das Argon-Case
ist gut, ist mir aber ein bisschen zu teuer.
Das für 11 Euro.
Na, ich kauf mir jetzt nicht jedes Raspberry Pi
Case zum ausprobieren.
Es gibt ja auch jetzt die Argon-Cases mit
NVMe und sowas drin.
Weißt du, was passiert ist? Was sagt der Umut
denn? Ähm...
IHK hatte meinen Projektantrag
nicht bekommen, obwohl ich den hochgeladen
hatte. Hab zum Glück den Antrag
runtergeladen gehabt und das gemerkt. Ja, sei
froh. Ist ja fast ähnlich wie bei mir gewesen.
Die sind
bei der IHK, die sind einfach echt
extrem unfähig.
Okay. Also Leute, ich würd sagen
Temperatur ist okay.
Okay, also.
Was ist denn so das...
Was ist denn so das Maximum,
was denn das Ding verträgt?
Arm Frequence Pi 4.
Mal gucken, was es da
results. Da gibt's
auch bestimmt Leute, die Tests gemacht
haben. Take it to the max.
Excellent.
Tom's Hardware. Ein Google-Eintrag
weiter.
Dass Tom's Hardware überhaupt noch gibt?
Okay, 200.
Ja, wie?
Die haben ja nur zwei
getestet. Was hat der hier
Maximum? Ach, mehr
geht nicht, oder was?
Ach, mehr geht nicht. Okay.
Also was? Overvoltage
6 und das. Okay,
komm, wir machen jetzt volle Pulle. Scheiß drauf. Easy.
Bam. Reboot.
Ich war mehr als nicht starten.
Kann er ja nicht. Und ich glaube im
Zweifelsfall tagt er das
sich halt runter, oder? Mal gucken.
Wupp, Wupp S.
Lebt er noch?
Patient scheint noch zu leben.
Postchamp. Postchamp.
Mal warten, bis der Login geht.
Da ist er. Da ist er, Leute.
2000...
2147.
Temp.
Dress.
Bam. Okay, jetzt geht
die Temperatur doch ganz gut hoch.
Die Frage ist halt, die man sich stellen muss,
ne? Macht man
auf diesem Ding ernsthaft irgendwas
großartig CPU
limitiertes, wo man
was braucht?
Ich mein, keiner, keiner
transcoded Videos auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Ich mein, es geht. Das ist das
wichtigste, ja? Minecrafts, okay.
Ja, ey, ohne Scheiß, für nen Minecraft
Server lass ich mir das gefallen, ja?
Ich mein, Minecraft
ist ja zumindest in der
Java Edition schon mal
da bekommt jedes Megaherz,
ne? Und bestimmt mit der
C++ Edition auch.
Wie benutzt du die Search Funktion
in der History? Steuerung R.
Und by the way, Steuerung
R sucht,
also ihr könnt jetzt sagen, das hier,
Steuerung R, dann gebt ihr den ersten
Dings ein. Und wenn ihr weiter Steuerung
R drückt, dann springt er immer
zu den nächsten Vorkommnissen. Und wenn
ihr Steuerung Shift R drückt, dann springt
er zurück. Und das
ist die
wichtigste,
die wichtigste Funktion,
die ihr jemals in eurer Shell
braucht. Weil,
wer ne lange Shell History
hat, der braucht keine
Server zu dokumentieren.
Einfach Shell nachgucken.
Meine History auf der Arbeit ist
glaub ich mittlerweile über 100.000
Zeilen lang. Und die wird auch
immer, die wird auch immer schön kopiert
von einer Installation zur nächsten.
Das ist Standard Bash
hier. Das, was
mit dem Raspberry kommt. Das hier bei mir
ist ZSH, die hier.
Clear.
Leute,
wir sind volle Pulle
übertaktet.
Genau, ihr müsst richtig das, was FIPS schreibt,
die Hist Size müsst ihr anpassen.
Und Hist File Size, sonst geht's nicht.
So, mal gucken, wie warm es ist.
Oh, oh ja.
Oh ja, Leute.
Das Gehäuse,
es ist unangenehm anzugreifen.
Definitiv.
Es tut schon leicht weh am Finger,
wenn man das zu lang drauf lässt auf dem Gehäuse.
Kennst du Spiffing Pritt?
Klar, wir haben schon ein paar Videos sogar hier zusammen geguckt.
Also, Maximum übertaktet
und
passiv gekühlt
schafft das Gehäuse
aber auch gerade
so
das Ding unter runter takten zu halten.
Und ich könnte mir
vorstellen, wenn es ein bisschen wärmer
ist im Sommer,
sodass die Raumtemperatur ein bisschen wärmer ist
und wenn es jetzt noch
zwei, drei Stunden läuft unter Volllast,
glaube ich, kommen wir auch ans Temperaturen
Limit in dem Gehäuse.
Ey, das ist echt warm, das Ding, ne?
Also, wenn ihr kalte
Füße habt nachts im Bett,
legt das Ding unter die Decke.
Oder erfreut
eure Frau, Freundin, wie auch immer
mit. Sagt der, guck mal hier,
ich hab Fußwärmer am Start.
Habt ihr auch gleich eine Ausrede,
warum Raspberry Pi ins Bett muss.
Da fehlt RGB.
Ich hab noch ein paar Neopixel.
Wir könnten RGB aufrüsten.
Ey, das wird echt warm.
Ich weiß aber
grad nicht genau, wo ich die Neopixel hab.
Ich hats
beim Aufräumen, ich hab heut
50 Mal gesagt, dass ich aufgeräumt habe
und jedes Mal, wo ich die Dinger aufgeräumt hab, wusste ich
vorher, wo sie sind. Jetzt, nachdem ich aufgeräumt
hab, weiß ich nicht mehr, wo die Dinger sind.
Wo könnte ich die Neopixel hin haben?
Ikea-Tasche. Ne, in der Ikea-Tasche.
Das alte Zeug, wo ich nicht wusste, wohin
damit. Vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht
haben wir Glück. Wir gucken mal in die
Magic-Box.
In die Magic-Microcontroller-Box,
ob da irgendwo die Neopixels drinne
sind. Wenn die Neopixels
drinne sind, dann können wir noch RGB-Beleuchtung
machen, ey.
Magic-Microcontroller-Box.
So.
Seht ihr irgendwo Neopixels?
Okay, ich geb zu, man erkennt jetzt nicht wirklich was.
Also.
Rüttelsensor.
Wir machen jetzt mal exquisite
Boxshow. Rüttelsensor.
Nein.
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Ein WiFi-Modul. Auch nicht.
Relays. Auch nicht.
Bewegungssensor.
Relay. Auch nicht.
ESP32-Dings-Gedöns.
Auch nicht.
Irgendwelche Stromdinger.
Mehr Relays.
Keine Ahnung.
Wo sind die Neopixels? Sind da irgendwo
Neopixels drin?
Sieht nicht so aus.
Keine Neopixels, Leute.
Sagt mir, wenn ihr irgendwo Neopixels...
Ihr wisst ja gar nicht, was ihr gucken müsst, aber...
Oh, guck mal!
Einfach random noch ein Raspberry Pi Zero drinne.
Lol, weh.
Rüttelsensor.
Alles keine Neopixels, Leute.
Hm.
Nee.
Sieht nicht so RGB-ig
aus gerade.
Okay, wo könnten
die Dinger noch sein?
Magic Microcontroller
Box wieder zumachen.
Keine Neopixels drin gewesen.
Arts Delivery.
Ja, beste.
Eats. Die haben echt
eine richtige Chance verschenkt, um sich
Eats Delivery zu nennen.
Eats Delivery wäre nun mal
wirklich mit Abstand der beste Name
von einem Lieferdienst überhaupt.
Wo könnte ich die
Neopixels haben?
Hm.
Ich geh mal draußen an den Schrank gucken. Mal ganz schnell.
In der Zwischenzeit, guck mal mal, wie warm
das... Oh, Leute.
Es schmilzt gleich.
Nee, Leute.
Leute, ich muss euch
enttäuschen. Ich find die Neopixels
jetzt auf die...
Auf die Schnelle nicht.
Das sind so einzelne
LEDs. Ich hab sogar
so ein paar LEDs, die man direkt per USB
anschließen kann, dann blinken lassen kann. Ich hab mir gedacht, wir machen
jetzt mal 10 Spass und machen eine Runde
RGB-Beleuchtung noch.
Ich guck noch mal schnell in die anderen Kartons, ob da
irgendwas drin ist.
Was ich da zurecht mache? Gar nix.
Raspberry Pi 4
ins Gehäuse eingebaut. Und jetzt mal gucken,
wie warm er wird. Aber Leute, wir sind
gleich am Temperaturlimit.
Wir sind auch... Temperaturlimit erreicht.
Gleich taktet er sich runter.
Monka
overclock.
Keine Chance, Leute.
Ich hab jetzt mal noch
zwei Kisten durchwühlt.
Keine RGB-Beleuchtung am Start.
Fields RGB Man.
Fields RGB Man. Wüsste ich nur,
wo ich den Kram hingemacht hab.
Ich hatte nämlich noch so ein paar
Blink-Dinger.
Die konntest du einfach in USB stecken.
Und dann...
Das Gehäuse...
Jetzt kann man den Finger nicht mal drauf lassen.
Das ist zu heiß.
Ohne Scheiß. Du kannst dich nicht mal angreifen.
Da verbrennst du dich auf Dauer,
wenn du nicht den Finger lang dran...
Keine gute Idee.
Deaktiviert das nicht automatisch
das Down-Clocking? Kein blassen Schimmer.
Aber er taktet sich nicht runter, oder?
Oben am Plastik?
Geht so.
Plastik ist okay.
Hot Case.
Ja, richtig.
Verbrenn-Case angesagt.
Also nicht...
Das ist auf jeden Fall deutlich zu heiß.
Aber das Gehäuse schafft's. Guck mal.
Kann sich nicht beschweren.
Maximum übertaktet.
Das Gehäuse schafft's
gerade so.
Aber wirklich ganz am Rande
das zu halten.
Doch top kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Poggers.
Alter.
Massive Pog.
Je nachdem, wie man's sieht.
Das ganze verbraucht
übrigens gerade...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr's seht.
Kennt man das?
Das ganze
braucht gerade...
9,2 Watt.
Also mehr
kannst du mit dem Raspberry Pi 3 anscheinend
nicht verbrauchen.
Du kannst noch ein bisschen I.O. machen.
Aber so bei
9,62 wie auch immer
ist Schluss.
Ist der Ding an vier Kerne?
Ja, genau.
Hochkant aufstellen.
Oh, jetzt kommen die Big Brainy.
Wir stellen jetzt Hochkant auf.
Mal gucken, ob er dann kälter wird.
Der bleibt nicht stehen, Hochkant.
Crap-Netzwerkkabel, Alter.
Bleibst du stehen.
Kein Q-Switch.
Bleibt nicht stehen.
Vielleicht so?
Diagonal aufstellen.
Ja.
Guck mal, jetzt hat er kaum Kontakt mit dem Boden.
Weiß jetzt nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Aber
das macht keinen Unterschied, Leute.
Ja gut, wenn du draufpustest...
Leute, wenn man draufpustet, wird's
natürlich kühler, das ist klar.
Ah, meine...
Wenn du draufpustest, wird's natürlich kühler.
Das kann ich euch...
Da hol ich mal was. Da kann ich euch was zeigen.
Hol mal was.
Jetzt werden wir das ganze Ding mal
aktiv kühlen.
Jetzt werden wir das ganze Ding mal aktiv kühlen.
Kühlchamp ist am Start.
Der Kühlchamp.
Den stellen wir uns jetzt am besten hin.
So, dass es am maximalsten vorbei geht.
Der Kühlchamp.
Achtung Kühlchamp activated.
Der Kühlchamp ist kaputt.
Oder? Ah, ne, der hat einen Knopf
hinten, lol, ah, Knopf.
Kühlchamp ist an.
Boah, pass mal auf, jetzt geht die
Temp runter wie nix.
Guck mal hier, jetzt geht die Temp runter wie nix.
Äh, keck, wait.
Keck.
Was ist das?
Ich glaub, ich, ich, ich, ich glaub,
das ist nicht, das ist nicht richtig gelagert
davor. Warte mal, das Ding nicht irgendwie
drehen?
Doch, guck mal, guck mal. Jetzt hier,
jetzt. Der Pusschamp ist
Oh, oh, ich hab Wärmeleit... Oh, fuck.
Ich hab Wärmeleitpaste unten dran hängen.
Äh, Sauerei.
Abmachen.
Naja, gut.
So, was macht die Temp?
80 Grad, 76 hier.
Der Puss-Champ kühlt ordentlich.
Ich muss das so machen irgendwie.
Das muss mehr an das Gehäuse dran.
Jetzt.
Boah, nee, so ist schon okay.
Der Puss-Champ, guckt euch das mal an.
Also man sieht, aktiv Kühlung bringt was, ja.
Gleich viel kühler das Gehäuse.
Guckt mal, jetzt könnt ihr den Raspberry Pi nicht nur als Fußwärmer verwenden, sondern auch als Heizungsersatz.
Nee, ich häng das Ding jetzt nicht aus dem Fenster.
An Minustemperatur.
Also ihr müsst das Fenster auch mal mit dem Raspberry Pi raushängen.
Guckt mal, 69 Grad.
Jetzt kann man das tatsächlich nicht nur als Fußwärmer, sondern echt als Heizung verwenden.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Also wenn ihr damit was heizen wollt, dauert ein bisschen.
Hey, aber theoretisch funktioniert das, ja.
Ich mein, wer hat sonst schon einen 9 Watt Heizlüfter?
Die haben sonst immer 2000.
Da freuen sich die Öko-Leute auch.
Haben einfach Energie gespart.
Wer braucht einen 2 kW Heizlüfter, wenn du auch einen 9 Watt Raspberry Pi Heizlüfter haben kannst?
Kannst du damit einen Raspberry Pi backen?
Oh, Painschip.
Der war schlecht, Alter.
Den Ventilator musst du da zurechnen.
Ja, okay.
Dann runde mal auf, keine Ahnung.
11, 12, meinetwegen, wenn es hochkommt, auf.
Aber mehr nicht.
Macht im Vergleich zu 2000 immer noch keinen Unterschied.
Ich mein, er heizt nicht.
Im Vergleich zu 2000 heizt er halt mal gar nicht.
Aber er heizt theoretisch, darauf kommt es an.
Theoretische, theoretische Heizleistung ist huge.
Nee, auch nicht.
Und man kann einen Minecraft-Server drauflaufen lassen.
Ich mein, überlegt euch mal, was du da, was du da der Umwelt alles Gutes tun kannst.
Du kannst Minecraft hosten und die Wohnung heizen.
Und das alles mit 50 Euro Einsatz, ja.
Das ist A++++ Energieklasse, ja.
Und steckt es in die Wohnung.
Stellt euch das Ganze jetzt nochmal, stellt euch hier die Kiste jetzt mit RGB vor.
Stellt euch vor, wir hätten hier einen Stick dran, der irgendwie richtig schön RGB-mäßig leuchtet, ja.
Sagt euch, das wäre hier exquisite.
Mit RGB wird das Ganze nochmal um 2, Faktor 2 geboostet werden.
Ja, mit RGB konnten wir auch locker auf 3 Gigahertz übertakten.
Safe, safe call, ja.
Gar kein Problem.
Das Gehäuse sieht ein bisschen...
...dreckig aus oben jetzt, ne.
Als ich mich das da eingerieben hab.
Vielleicht sollte ich das mal echt sauber machen.
Ich hab halt nur nix da.
Ich hab nur dieses komische Papier hier da.
Was ehrlich gesagt nichts sauber macht.
Tja.
Leute.
Da haben wir's.
Aber das Gehäuse ist wirklich Poggers, ne.
Also, jetzt mal ganz ohne Spaß.
Viel dummes Zeug gelabert.
Letzte Viertelstunde.
Aber das Gehäuse ist wirklich nice.
Das sieht nicht nur gut aus, das hat alle notwendigen Funktionen.
Du hast sogar eine Anzeige, was die LEDs macht, was die LEDs macht.
Kommst an alles dran, inklusive SD-Karte, Mikro-USB, Audio.
Es gibt ja übrigens Geräte, die noch einen Audio-Ausgang haben, so einen Klinkenstecker.
Kommst hier hinten an alles dran und das Gehäuse bleibt schön, schön kühl, wenn man das nicht
Maximum übertaktet und volle Pulle vier Kerne laufen lässt.
Stimmt, das sind Mikro-HDMI.
Wie komm ich auf Mikro-USB?
Durchschnitts-Mikro-HDMI, ja.
An, an den Kameraanschluss kommst du tatsächlich nicht dran, wobei du da auch deine Probleme
hast, wie kriegst du das Kamerakabel raus.
Das würde aber alle, das würde wahrscheinlich hier neben funktionieren.
Guck mal.
Hier neben hast du eine Öffnung drin im Gehäuse.
Du müsstest das Kamerakabel durchmachen, ja.
Das wird funktionieren.
Das kannst du ja anschließen und dann hier daneben raus machen.
Ja, das wird gehen.
So, wir machen den Puzzle-Champ mal wieder aus.
Ärgert mich, dass ich kann man immer, dass die RGB-Dinger nicht funktionieren.
Weil ich finde, nee, echt keine Ahnung, wo die RGB-USB-Dinger sind.
Na gut, was das ist, auf Slot 0, das kann ich dir zeigen.
Lass da.
Gibt's für den Pi 4 schon eine zukünftige Aufgabe?
Ja, der ist rein für den Stream da.
Ich habe den mir extra neu gekauft, weil den letzten Raspberry Pi, den ich für den Stream
hatte, der wurde zu meinem neuen Unify Access Point, äh, nicht Access Point, Unify-Controller.
Da habe ich den alles.
Da habe ich den alten Raspberry Pi 3 abgelöst, der ist nur für den Stream, sonst nix, wenn
wir irgendwelche Sachen ausprobieren.
Also hier ist kein Problem, ich kann's mal ausprobieren, ich hab, ich hab, moin, ich hab
hier irgendwo nen, ich hab hier doch in der Ikea-Tasche eben nen, wartet mal, nen HDMI
gesehen.
Hier, guckt mal, kann ich euch zeigen, guckt mal, HDMI, gar kein Problem, funzt, passt
wunderbar, alles gut, perfekt.
Exzellent sozusagen, exquisite.
So, wir machen jetzt mal die, die BigBrain Noctua Wärmeleitpaste wieder zu, bevor's
noch mehr kleckert, das Ding, zu und wieder hier rein.
Braucht man bestimmt noch mal.
Dieses komische eingesiffte Ding kommt da auch rein, was immer das ist.
Ref-Link für das Case, nee, hab ich nicht.
Klickt einfach irgendeinen Ref-Link von mir an und kauft's dann.
Das zählt für das Case.
Das zählt für alles, was man kauft.
Wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Ja, Leute, so sieht's aus.
Mehr Content hab ich für heut' nicht geplant.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen im Chat?
Hab ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen?
Zeig's mal her.
Cute Chat.
Du hast jetzt nen 3D-Drucker gekauft?
Exzellent.
Hab ich an Weihnachten.
Achso, Tutorial, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon.
Dinger heißen offiziell Rüttelsensor.
Ich glaub, großartig, Erdbeben erkennen, keine Ahnung, ob das so gut damit funktioniert.
Ja, doch, wahrscheinlich auch.
Zeit für VU.
Wir können mal gucken, ob ein Server, ähm, wie, keck, wait, ja, aber sagen wir mal so,
ins Bett wird, wird doch gehen, oder?
Das sieht ja mega hässlich aus, äh, das kann, das kann man doch heute wahrscheinlich schon
ziemlich easy machen, oder?
Wow.
Achso, weil's die GPA ausdurchleitet, okay.
Ja, das hatten wir eigentlich alles schon, ne, ich hab nix übersehen, oder?
Nix übersehen.
Ja, wie gesagt, für 20 Euro kriegst du ja schon das komplette Case, was ich da gezeigt
hab, ne?
Also kriegst du für 20 Euro, kriegst du ja schon ungefähr, für 21 Euro kriegst du ja
schon das komplette, das komplette Case.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie sinnvoll das ist, da nen, nur nen Lüfter zu kaufen für, na
gut, wenn man Lüfter haben will und an die GPA auskommen will, ist das tatsächlich nicht
schlecht, weil an die GPA auskommst du hier nicht.
Äh, GPIO-Champ ist hier nicht.
Das Argon Neo, ja, das kann man sich auch kaufen, das ist hier nicht schlecht.
Die Argon Cases sind eigentlich auch ganz gut immer.
GPIO mit Flachbandkabel, das würde funktionieren, ja.
Wie verwaltest du deine ganzen Daten, Nextcloud NAS, ich hab ne NAS.
Ich hab auch Nextcloud für den, für den Sync zwischen ein paar Rechnern, aber ich
mag Nextcloud überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich will das schon seit, seit ganzen Wochen.
Das seit einer ganzen Weile ablösen, bin aber noch zu faul für.
Macht dann wahrscheinlich eh ne Kombination aus Sync-Thing und irgendeinem normalen Kaldav-Server
oder so, weil Nextcloud ist pain in the ass.
Fährst du nach Dresden, wenn der Friseur wieder am Start ist?
Ich würd gern mal wieder nach Dresden fahren.
Es war schon nice.
Ich weiß nicht, wie schnell mein 3D-Drucker druckt.
Hab ich doch, ich hab da Default-Settings.
Tja, so.
Okay.
So, aber jetzt, wenn da grad einer sagt, VU, ich guck mal schnell in VU rein.
By the way, ich muss euch mal was fragen, Leute, jetzt mal, hat, hat nix mit, mit Battlefield
oder, oder Raspberry Pi Cases zu tun, ich hab auf, ich hab manchmal Lack, wenn ich den
Windows-Knopf drück.
Wenn ich den Windows-Knopf drück, dann laggt's zwei, drei Sekunden, Explorer-Auslastung geht
auf 10% hoch.
Ich glaub, das ist irgendwie ein Problem von Windows.
Weil, weil mein Desktop zu voll ist, jetzt ohne Scheiß, mein Desktop ist ja auf meinem
Main-Account noch viel voller.
Kennt das jemand?
Lack, wenn man Windows-Taste drückt?
Okay, Leute, Dead Game, Dead Game, Pain's Champ, Game Dead, und dann auch Trash Map.
Hast du auch?
Komisch.
Mit Deluxe wär das nicht passiert, ja, das stimmt.
Aber wenn wir's noch mehr haben, ist es bestimmt ein Windows-Bug und wird hoffentlich gefixt
mit einem der nächsten, ähm.
Roll-Ups da.
Okay, Chat, und dann hab ich noch mal eine andere Frage an euch.
So, mal an die krassen Web-Web-Web-Web-Entwicklung-Champs, bisschen kleiner kurz, aber ich lass es da,
so.
Mal eine Frage an die Web-Entwicklungs-Champs von euch.
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären, warum das so angesagt ist, Tailwind CSS?
Ich versteh's nicht so ganz.
Das ist voll im Hype aktuell.
Weil.
Also, habt ihr mal eine Idee, warum das so beliebt ist?
Weil ist das nicht, ist das nicht im Endeffekt wie Inline-CSS schreiben?
Das ist, das ist wie Inline-CSS schreiben.
Und Inline-CSS ist doch voll verpönt.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich persönlich mag Inline-CSS eigentlich.
Da kannst es genau dahin schreiben, wo Sache ist.
Ähm.
Ist das, ist das für Leute, die gerne Inline-CSS schreiben?
Ja.
Genau.
Und das für Leute, die Inline-CSS verwenden und das bisschen ordentlicher machen wollen.
Also, Leute.
Ich weiß schon, was es macht.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum Inline-CSS auf der einen Seite so verpönt ist und auf
der anderen Seite Tailwind voll angesagt ist.
Weil dazu kommt.
Es ist ja kein UI-Framework in dem Sinn, dass du da fertige Buttons, fertige Tabellen und
fertige Switches, fertige Cards oder sonst was bekommst.
Du musst ja trotzdem alles noch selber schreiben.
Alles noch selber stylen.
Man schreibt sein CSS ins HTML, ja.
Also so genau habe ich das noch nicht gecheckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Check ich nicht.
Du schreibst kein CSS ins HTML?
Na, im Prinzip schon.
Unter der Haube sind das natürlich irgendwelche vordefinierten CSS-Klassen,
aber mal ganz im Ernst, also.
Das ist schon im Prinzip so eine Art CSS ins HTML.
Nur, dass, sag mal so, die Klassen sind halt für dich definiert.
Es ist ein bisschen wie Inline-Styles.
Und ich verstehe halt nicht, warum Inline-Styles auf der einen Seite verpönt sind
und das hier voll geil gefunden wird.
Ich finde es vom Ansatz her auch nice.
Ich mag ja auch Inline-Styles, ja.
Aber ich werde das mal ausprobieren.
Vielleicht sagt mir das ja zu.
Warum ich so ein Kram wie Beautify oder so verwende, ist,
weil ich im Design von UI-Elementen sacke.
Und ich da fertige Sachen habe.
Da, mit Tailwind muss ich ja immer noch, also da ist,
das ist ja wirklich nur ein Ersatz für CSS schreiben.
Also sprich, ich muss immer noch alles selbst stylen.
Also, wenn man zwei linke Hände hat, was Webdesign angeht, dann...
Wobei, man könnte auch den Serious Max fragen.
Der ist ja hier Massive Frontend Big Brain Designer.
Das wäre eh das Beste.
Ich lasse einfach andere Leute Frontend machen.
Easy.
Hör mir auf.
Wieso?
Der Preis-Champ-Prototyp sah doch echt geil aus.
Herr Agilene, der gibt sich mit so easy Sachen nicht ab.
Wir waren heute auf der...
Der Arbeit übrigens super agil.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das schon noch gezeigt habe.
Guck mal.
Also, Alternate ist auch mit...
Das neue Alternate ist auch mit Tailwind gemacht.
Guckt mal.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder zumindest mit was ziemlich ähnlichem.
Ist das, ist das Tailwind?
Oder ist das was Custom Alternatiges?
Weil sowas ist auch in Tailwind drin.
Meinst du, das ist Bootstrap?
Nee.
Das ist kein Bootstrap.
Das sieht nicht Bootstrap-y aus.
Oder Custom-Zeug, ja.
Wobei, NAFBA-Item, das könnte auch...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Das könnte auch wirklich Bootstrap sein.
Ja, doch, doch.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Das ist Bootstrap.
Guckt mal.
Ja, das ist Bootstrap.
Na klar.
Delta, warum nicht?
Guckt mal, wie agil wir heute waren auf der Arbeit.
Heute Nacht ging was kaputt.
Ich hab mit nem Kollege drüber geschrieben.
Er hat direkt festgestellt, wo der Fehler lag.
Wir haben noch ein dummes Bild gepostet.
Ich hab's gecherrypickt und der Fehler war weg.
Also wenn das nicht mal agil ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Innerhalb von 5 Minuten vom Fehler entdeckt,
zu Fehler gefixt,
von Fehler cherrypickt und deployed.
Das ist sowas von Agile, Alter.
Das sollte den Scrum-Preis 2021 gewinnen.
Gibt's eigentlich sowas?
Scrum-Preis?
Scrum-Master-Preis?
Nee.
Preisverleihung.
Es gibt kein Scrum-Preis.
Auszeichnung.
Es gibt kein Scrum-Master-of-the-Year oder sowas.
Marktlücke.
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen sowas ins...
Competitive Scrum.
Ja.
So wie es Competitive Programming gibt.
Competitive Scrum.
Wer macht die schnellste Sprintplanung?
Und das schönste Kanban-Board?
Agile Champ.
Ja, genau.
Kannst du mein Java-GUI bewerten?
Äh.
Ja.
Gucken, was da für ein Bild jetzt aufgeht, Alter.
Äh.
Ja, viel GUI ist da nicht vorhanden.
Es sieht halt Java-Style aus, ne?
Ist das Java-FX oder was ist das?
Es sieht halt typisch...
Es sieht halt typisch, typisch, typisch Java-Crap aus.
Das sieht halt nur mal so aus, das Zeug bei Java.
Also, viel GUI ist da ja nicht.
Dass das hier alles klippt, ist Crap.
Und ich hab den Eindruck, dass die...
Dass du mir das Bild geschickt hast, ist...
Ist eigentlich ein großer G-Bait.
Massive G-Bait.
Das Webscale.
Das diagonal skaliert.
Kannst du Java-Pluglisten?
Ne.
Die Chinesen mögen Java.
Ich sag's jedem Stream.
GitHub-Trends sind...
Sind zur Hälfte Chinesen-Repos...
Sind zur Hälfte Chinesen-Repos aus...
Äh, mit Java.
Passt auf.
Ich sag's euch.
Okay.
China...
Okay, was ist Mini-View?
Ah ja, alles klar.
Okay.
Mhm, mhm, mhm.
Ah, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Exquisite.
Das denk ich mir auch immer.
Mh, perfekt.
Alles klar.
Dogo-Coin ist am Start.
Very currency.
Stonks-Ticker.
Ja, endlich.
Ein Golang-Stonks-Ticker.
Da hab ich drauf gewartet.
In China ist die Bahn ausgefallen, weil Flash nicht mehr ging.
Wo sind die ganzen China-Repos?
Was ist denn hier los?
Von dem Typ...
Von dem Typ hab ich mal einen Webcast geguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der das ist.
Ähm...
Da hab ich mir echt an den Kopf gegriffen.
Falls das das ist, vielleicht tu ich dem jetzt hier Unrecht.
Ich mein, das ist recht beliebt, das Repo.
Da wird schon sinnvolle Sachen drin sein.
Aber von dem hab ich mal...
Da hab ich mal einen Konferenztalk geguckt.
Und...
Der hat in C-Sharp unter akuter...
Wie soll ich das ausdrücken?
Interfaceritis gelitten.
Der hat keine normalen Klassen verwendet.
Der hat aus allem ein Interface gemacht.
Und irgendwann, zur Mitte des Talks, hat er anstatt Date-Time zu verwenden,
ein Interface iDate-Time gemacht.
Und dann darunter abstrahiert Date-Time verwendet, und dann hab ich ausgemacht.
Das war mir zu dumm, Alter.
iDate-Time, Alter.
Da war's vorbei.
Warum macht man das?
Weil Clean-Architecture...
Die sind so clean...
Die brauchen erstmal 500 Zeilen, bevor sie anfangen können, damit's clean ist.
Ich mein, iDate-Time, what the fuck?
Als würde sich das ändern.
Als müsste ich irgendwie mal Date-Time, die Date-Time-Implementierung einfach mal austauschen.
Gut, dass ich das gemacht hab.
Gut, dass ich da ein abstrahiertes Interface hab.
Ja, ganz wichtig.
Wo sind die China-Repos?
Gar keine China-Repos.
Leute, ich hab euch gescamt.
Oh.
Leute, mein Handy ist ausgegangen.
Und wisst ihr auch warum?
Keck, wait.
Wisst ihr, warum das ausgegangen ist?
Weil ich vergessen hab, den Stromstecker reinzustecken.
Massive Brain, Max.
Huge.
Huge Brain.
Und ich muss den aufladen.
Gut, Webcam ist vorbei.
Okay, also.
Hä? War das nicht das, wo SemperVideo gewarnt hat davor?
Haben die das jetzt geforkt?
Oder was ist da los?
Okay.
Warum trendet das denn?
Aha.
Okay, also, hier.
Erste China-Repo.
Was ist es?
China-Sachen.
MonkaS.
Das ist bestimmt Java.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich hab keine Asia-Schriftarten installiert.
Javascript.
Was ist das schon wieder?
Es vergeht keine Woche ohne neue Javascript-Frameworks.
Was ist WhiteJS schon wieder?
Wollt ihr beim Createless Panda nachdenken?
Nee, mich hat es gewundert, dass das Repo trendet.
Weil das Malware-Zeug hat.
Wisst ihr, was wirklich significantly
die Frontend-Experience
erhöhen würde?
Wenn es nicht jede Woche
ein neues Javascript-Framework gäbe?
Was macht das überhaupt?
Instant-Server-Start, Lightning-Fast, HMR.
Was ist denn HMR?
Refresh?
Page-Refresh oder so?
Leute, die Sache ist die,
ich habe das jetzt gelesen,
ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Was ist es überhaupt?
Hotmodule
Guide
Introduction
Okay
Ah, das ist, okay, das ist ein eigener Webpack
oder sowas.
Okay, verstehe.
So, Chinesen sind nochmal am Start.
Java
Java? Ich sag doch, die China-Repos
sind alle in Java.
Da ist schon wieder iDate-Time-Typ.
Secure and Fast Micro-VMs
for Serverless Computing
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das habe ich tatsächlich schon mal gesehen.
Ich habe wieder komplett verdrängt, was es ist.
Aber das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Ist das nicht von Amazon gewesen?
War das nicht von Amazon?
Ja doch, genau.
Genau.
Irgendwelche Cloud-Native-Diagonal-Web-Scale-Agile-Lösung, ja.
Hat Jeff selbst entwickelt.
Genau.
Open-Source-Crypto-Trading-Bot
Boah, kann man da mit
stonks Money machen?
Jetzt weiß ich, was ich mit meinem
Raspberry Pi mache.
Stonks Crypto-Trade-Bot
Jawoll!
7 Euro, Poggers!
Hyperopt.
Jawoll!
Crypto-Bot.
Laufen lassen.
Das neue Windows-Terminal hat ernsthaft
71.000 Sterne!
Das neue
Windows-Terminal ist ungefähr jetzt
auf einem halbwegs
unmittelbaren Stand.
Also das, was beispielsweise Gnome-Terminal
oder die anderen Linux-Terminals schon seit
15 Jahren sind.
Aber die Windows-User sind so happy,
dass sie nicht mehr
diesen Shit hier verwenden müssen,
dass sie dem Ding einfach 71.000 Sterne
auf GitHub geben.
Es ist einfach nur ein normales Terminal,
was funktioniert.
Das neue Windows-Terminal. Nur.
Ja?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es installiert habe.
Was mich im
Windows-Terminal nervt in dem
neuen auch, dass man nicht richtig per mittlerer Maustaste
copy-pasten kann.
Also, was spricht denn dagegen,
jetzt mal für die Leute, die öfters WSL
verwenden,
was spricht denn dagegen,
einen X-Server auf Windows zu installieren,
ein ordentliches Terminal
zu installieren und darin dann seine
Shell laufen zu lassen? Wäre das nicht noch besser
oder gibt es dann Probleme im Zusammenarbeit
mit irgendwelchen Windows-Tools?
Emoji-Support, ja. Wichtig.
Ganz wichtig.
Die wollten mit WSL 2
Jaja, man kann da irgendwie
weiß ich, ob es Beta war
mit X-Server
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich verfolge das nicht so
häufig.
Ähm.
MAUI glaube ich nicht, dass das
was richtig Gutes wird.
MAUI ist ja quasi Xamarin oder
Xamarin Reloaded und
die machen irgendwie unter Linux
so ein komisches
halt GTK oder so Sackt.
Ich glaube, das taugt nichts.
Ich glaube, eine wirklich sinnvolle Alternative
für Cross-Plattform
Desktop-Gui-Entwicklung
wird es erst geben, wenn Flutter
auf dem Desktop richtig gut funktioniert.
Ansonsten hast du im Prinzip zwei Sachen.
Du hast Qt und da musst du dich
mit C++ rumschlagen.
Ähm.
Oder du hast Elektron.
Was auch Sackt.
Ja, Uno und Avalonia gibt es
auch noch, aber da weiß ich nicht, wie
gut die
funktionieren.
Also Xamarin hat GTK verwendet
unter der Haube, unter Linux, ja.
Was anderes? Andere Möglichkeit gibt es
ja nicht, was Cross-Plattform-Gui.
Also ich glaube so richtig ordentliches
Desktop-Cross-Plattform-Gui werden wir erst
kriegen in neuen
Competitor, wenn Flutter
auf dem Desktop gut funktioniert.
Ja.
Microsoft kriegt es ja nicht einmal geschissen
ein ordentliches Gui-Framework unter Windows
zum Laufen zu bringen.
WinUI 3.
Haben sie ja auch mal wieder
so massiv verkackt
bei Microsoft, wo ich mich frage,
wie kann man es so krass verkacken?
Sie wollten
eigentlich Native Apps, also
normale Windows Apps,
kein UWP-Geschiss unterstützen.
Unpackaged.
Und was unterstützen sie jetzt?
Nur Packaged.
Guck mal mal, wann ist da
die nächste Roadmap?
Die nächste Roadmap gibt.
WinForms All Changed My Mind.
Ja, Emoji Support zum Beispiel.
Mind Changed.
Wie sieht es denn mit Unmanaged aus?
Unpackaged. Geht das jetzt?
Jaja, ich weiß, dass ihr angeblich
Unpackaged unterstützen wollt, aber
wolltet ihr auch schon zum Letzten?
Stimmt ja überhaupt nicht, ja.
Geht doch überhaupt nicht Unpackaged.
Lügt nicht Microsoft, ich habe es ausprobiert.
Also Unpackaged heißt,
man kann einfach wie gehabt eine Windows Anwendung
erstellen und dann GUI drin machen und gut ist.
Das Problem aktuell ist,
Packaged Apps sind so Sachen, die man
beispielsweise bei UWP auch gemacht hat,
wo man ein extra
Code Signing Zertifikat braucht.
Und das Problem ist, keiner,
der so wie ich mal privat
die ein oder andere Windows Anwendung macht,
kauft sich ein Code Signing Zertifikat.
Selbst wenn es nur
150 Euro im Jahr kostet.
Macht niemand. Sehe ich auch überhaupt nicht ein.
Okay, Unpackaged ist hier
richtig, richtig Crap.
Geht immer noch nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was mit Microsoft.
Ich meine, mal im Ernst,
wie schafft es Microsoft eigentlich noch
Windows zu verkaufen?
Oder besser gesagt, wie schafft es Microsoft überhaupt noch
Entwickler dazu
zu bewegen, Desktop Anwendungen für Windows
zu machen?
Desktop Anwendungen auf
Windows sind echt
der übelste Abfuck.
Die Auswahl zwischen,
was heißt jetzt eigentlich TOS, Terms of Service?
Die haben,
du hast zur Auswahl unter Windows,
Windows Forms, was ich an sich
gar nicht schlecht finde, aber halt übelst
oldschool ist und keine neuen Sachen kann.
Dann hast du UWP, was ein bisschen neuer ist,
aber auch schon zu alt, um die richtig interessanten
neuen Sachen zu können. Und dann
hast du, WPF meine ich,
und dann hast du UWP, das ist neu,
suckt aber, weil du kaum
was oder vieles nicht machen kannst.
Und unpackaged schon mal gar nicht,
ohne Zertifikat.
Also, es gibt
nix. Ich weiß nicht, wie Microsoft
es schafft, dass Leute noch Desktop Anwendungen machen.
Und dann muss man sich doch nicht wundern,
wenn die Hälfte der
neuen Desktop Anwendungen
besteht aus
Elektron und JavaScript.
Eigentlich ist nur WPF richtig sinnvoll.
Naja, ja, aber
WPF ist halt auch kacke eigentlich im aktuellen
2021.
Weiß gar nicht, ob du mittlerweile einen neuen
WebView hast oder immer noch nicht mit dem alten
IE-Scheiß rumschlagen musst.
Auch DirectX-Integration
beziehungsweise Direct3D-Integration
in WPF ist reudig.
Ja, gehen tut's, aber schön ist es nicht.
Emoji-Support und
neueste Sachen gibt's auch nicht drinnen.
Also im Prinzip, dir bleibt
ja nix anderes übrig, als
ne Elektron-Anwendung zu machen. Oder du machst
ne Qt-Anwendung,
dann kannst du wenigstens
Mac, Linux, Windows gleichermaßen
beglücken.
Dann hast du da wieder andere Probleme
und vor allem ist es C++.
Genau, deswegen sind so viele Apps
JavaScript. Gerade unter Windows.
Sagt halt
einfach Massive, was Microsoft da macht.
Apple macht's ein bisschen
besser. Apple hat einen
riesen Vorteil.
Die machen nicht die Sache wie Microsoft,
dass die alle vier Jahre ihre Designrichtlinien
ändern. Ja, mal Ribbon Bars,
mal keine Ribbon Bars,
mal Aero, mal kein Aero,
mal Flat Design, mal kein Flat Design,
mal was auch immer. Microsoft denkt sich ja
laufend was anderes aus.
Apple macht das
auch, aber Apple macht das insofern on the fly
und ist da auch hartnäckig, dass
die Leute sich dran halten. Also
die kriegen das besser hin.
Ja und unter Linux ist es
auch nicht wirklich besser,
weil unter
Linux ist halt generell
die sind sich da nicht so wirklich
einig genug unter Linux.
Du hast 20 verschiedene Desktops.
Du hast die
Gnome Leute, die laufend was kaputt machen.
Und im Prinzip
GTK halt rein für Gnome optimieren
und deswegen macht keiner
nicht wirklich GTK Anwendungen.
Man darf nicht vergessen, VLC
war ja früher mal eine GTK Anwendung.
Aber die haben gesagt,
leckt uns, oder leckt mich, hab keinen Bock drauf.
Haben's jetzt auf Qt umgestellt.
Also GTK ist halt
auch Crap.
Das einzige was gut ist unter Linux ist Qt.
Allerdings KDE suckt.
Also für mich, ich mag KDE
nicht. Also
die Desktop Umgebung, die mit dem
einzig guten GUI Framework
programmiert ist, suckt.
Aber das ist eher eine Geschmacksfrage. Ich mag halt
KDE nicht. KDE ist Pantschamp.
Die Pi Foundation installiert
ungefragt ein Microsoft Repo. Ja gut.
Warum nicht?
Die installieren auch ungefragt
Debian Repos.
Was ist denn Schlimmes drin in dem
Microsoft Repo? Wahrscheinlich
das ganze .NET Zeug, oder?
Das finde ich persönlich gar nicht schlecht, wenn das da
standardmäßig drin ist.
Visual Studio Code.
Warum nicht?
Ach mit den Badges, stimmt.
Da müssten wir auch noch was machen, ja.
Naja, also Desktop
Anwendung ist wirklich Pantschamp.
Deswegen bin ich in letzter Zeit auch
quasi komplett drauf
umgeschwungen, mich ein bisschen mehr mit
Websachen zu beschäftigen.
Weil man hat einfach viele Probleme
nicht, wenn man die Sachen im Web laufen lässt.
Du hast Instant Support
für alle
Mobile Plattformen,
für alle Desktop Plattformen
und die wichtigsten Sachen kannst
du heute auch im Browser machen.
Also so wirklich richtig Native
Apps bräuchte man zum Beispiel
für
irgendwelche Screenshot Tools
oder so. Weiß ich nicht, ob man das im Browser
gescheit machen kann, sowas.
Ja, also für Screenshot Tools, die dann in der Tat
in der Taskleiste sind, sich Hotkeys registrieren
und sowas. Für solche Sachen brauchst du Native
Apps noch, aber ansonsten
so die meisten anderen Sachen, die
Leute täglich benutzen, sind
halt mittlerweile im Browser und
Leute, die es dann auf dem Desktop bringen wollen, die machen es
halt in Elektron, weil es keine gescheiten Desktop
Frameworks gibt. Ja, und
Firefox hat gesagt, sie bringen keinen PWA
Support auf dem Desktop, was halt auch sagt.
Genau so ein Tool, wie ich mal für
BDO gebastelt hab, die die Screenshots
analysiert, ja. Das geht, das
geht nur Native. Und das geht auch nicht mit UWP.
Ich versteh es einfach nicht,
warum Microsoft nicht ihren Kram,
ihr WinUI endlich mal rausbringt
für stinknormale Win32
Unpackaged Apps.
Dann hättste ne Chance,
äh, quasi
sowas
hier zu bauen
mit halbwegs
modernem Windows GUI
mit halbwegs modernem Zeug
Unpackaged
und kein UWP Crap.
Aber das, wie gesagt, es läuft
mir nicht ein. Die einzigen, die das halbwegs
gescheit hinkriegen sind, Apple,
weil auf Linux sieht es nicht wirklich besser
aus. Auf Linux
ist es aber andere Probleme.
Unter Linux streitet man
sich lieber zwei Jahre.
Wer dran schuld ist, dass Hardwarebeschleunigung
im Browser für Videos nicht funktioniert,
Hardwaredecoding. Ja, was
Paint 3D, ich benutze Paint 3D nie.
Ich wollte es jetzt nur mal für das GUI zeigen,
ja.
Weil die andere UWP-Anwendung, die manche
Leute öfters verwenden, ist der Taschenrechner.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt
GUI-mäßig echt eines der hässlichsten
Programme, die es überhaupt gibt.
Das sieht aus, als hat es, also
die Oberfläche sieht aus, als hat es irgendwie
der Designpraktikant in den
ersten Viertelstunde gebastelt.
Ey, guckt euch das mal an.
Was soll, was ist das?
Grau in Grau
und über allen Button hingeschissen.
Aber cool, dass
der Hintergrund durchschimmert, ne?
Videobeschleunigung in Firefox geht erst
seit, keine Ahnung, einem Monat oder so
und auch nur unter ganz
speziellen Bedingungen.
Und ich glaube, bis heute nicht mit allen
Videoformaten.
H.265 geht, glaube ich, immer noch nicht
und wie es mit VP9 aussieht oder
oder, oder Dings, ähm, nicht VP9.
Ähm.
Ja, ist ja andere Kram.
Ich glaube, es geht nur H.264 und auch nur mit
den passenden Grafik, mit der passenden Grafikkarte,
mit den passenden Grafikkartentreibern,
mit einer neuesten Firefox-Version,
eventuell noch irgendwelchen Hidden Flags gesetzt,
Firefox, spezieller Videocodec
und noch die passenden Libraries
installiert. Also,
ne? Es ist, es ist
Crap. Es ist wirklich...
Also Desktop, die müssen sich nicht wundern,
wenn die Leute keinen Bock mehr auf den Desktop haben.
Das einzige, was halt gut auf dem Desktop ist,
sind Spiele und die sind auch am besten unter Windows
und warum das so gut funktioniert
ist, weil du halt
in, in Spielen nichts, äh,
Cross-Plattformen in dem Sinn brauchst, ja?
Und wenn schon, ist es selbst gemalt
und selbst getraw, also selbst, selbst
erschaffen, ja?
Dann kannst du das auch machen.
Du brauchst da kein GUI-Framework, was Cross-Plattform ist für.
Ich meine, es ist schon so weit,
dass die Leute Game-Engines als
Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework für Desktop-
Anwendungen verwenden. Muss ich mir mal
vorstellen, also da, da fehlt eindeutig
was.
Aber Microsoft kriegt's nicht gebacken.
Du hast natürlich immer noch die
Auswahl Qt und C++ zu verwenden,
aber mal ganz im Ernst,
das ist ja noch, noch schlimmer.
Also Qt, ich, ich
mag Qt als Framework,
aber C++, ich weiß, dass es
Python-Bindings gibt, aber da hast du andere,
andere Sorgen dann wieder.
Ähm, und
ich glaub für, für wirklich Erweiterungen
brauchst du,
ähm, wie hieß das?
Wir haben
noch letztens einen im Chat, der uns sogar die,
seine Android-App
gezeigt hat, die in,
war das, war das Godo,
Godo spricht man's glaub ich aus.
Godo,
war das, glaub ich,
ich bin mir nicht mal ganz sicher,
der hat, äh, ne Android,
ne Cross-Platform-GUI-App gemacht in der
Game Engine und hat als letztes sogar den,
den, den Android-Store-Link
dazu geschickt im Chat.
Ja.
Ja, kann ich auch verstehen, warum die das machen,
weil die ganzen Cross-GUI-Platform-
Frameworks kacke sind.
Äh. Ach was, Leute.
So, 21.35.
Jetzt off.
Macht's gut.
Jetzt
machen wir noch
Outromusik.
Wir sehen uns, Leute. Bis denn.
See you.